e
e e
um we have bills to talk about this
afternoon and for those bills we've got
the sponsors and others coming in at
various points but we're going to fill
in all the remaining time with with
reading through and and just getting
organized with houseu to um and so we're
going to start house build two stuff now
and I think we have a very thick
presentation on group two from the
retirement system so please kind of come
up
here and so this is what we're talking
about out here I guess is the um
sections let's see here in House Bill 2
um that are where are they uh Pages 25
through
39 sections 25 through
65 hi good morning Mr chair my name is
Jan Goodwin I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire retirement system
um with me is Mark Kavanaugh our deputy
chief Council and he has put together a
comparison of the group two tier B
legislation that compares those aspects
from House Bill 2 from
2023 and this year's House Bill 2 2025
excellent so um it's a onepage summary
with the two Actuarial reports someone
want to dive into the numbers um
essentially these bills are almost
identical uh the the main substantive
difference is that the 2025 Bill does
not have an increase in the maximum
benefit like the 2023 Bill had um that's
a very nominal amount of money according
to the actuary uh we don't have an
actual Dollar on it yet
um the other uh difference okay doesn't
have a maximum benefit so what was the
previous maximum benefit was it was like
somebody's salary 100,000 versus they
were increasing at
$5,000 okay and and when it comes to the
maximum benefit it's higher paid people
who are going to get close to that not
not people with long service because
group one you got to work 62 years to
get to 100% which which is the other
part of the limit right um oh so the
limit on is 100% or 125 and you nobody
ever gets to 100% or not many people
work 62 years it's only 40 if you're if
you're group two so that's possible we
know the longest serving guy is in the
50e range
right anyway 62 so he has to work
another 10 years so I mean when we talk
about the numbers I can point out gotcha
uh how little it would be okay go ahead
so just to clarify when we talk about
the numbers that
[Music]
um the valuation from our actuaries for
hb2 is actually the valuation they did
earlier this year for HB
727 so HB 727 is the same as hb2 except
for the maximum benefit part as well and
we we expect to get it an official
updated valuation from the actuary uh
this week is HP 727
still in progress or do we know it was
or was this last year you're talking
about it was retained in Ed yeah oh
retained okay thank
you um so the second difference is that
hb2
2025 differs from 727 of this year and
from the 2023 bill in that it appears to
eliminate uh a limit on extra and
special Duty that existed since 200
uh prior to 2011 we think this was a
scrier error and we want to uh point
that out we will in our uh fiscal note
so you think we need to fix this yeah so
when they B under this bill they're
bifurcating the definition earnable comp
between group one and group two so they
took the section out of the group one
definition because they don't have
special Duty I think they just forgot to
put it back into the group two section
because this is not a tier B rule this
is a tier a rule that limits High three
special duty to the average over year
what do you mean by tier B the the
different ages of the yeah tier B is the
group that's this bill is designed to
okay Help the people who were not vested
not yet vested yeah okay fine yeah we we
call them we have tiers now I see tier a
is everyone who was vested tier B is
everyone who was hired but not vested in
tier C of people hired after 112
gotcha so um so this doesn't help tier C
this does not help tier C okay okay
that's new hires which now
um I don't have new hires as of on or
after 11
2012 which oh is getting to be a
substantial portion of our total
membership you know Mr chair 13 years
all right represented month could could
you just could you just go through that
one more time the the T a tier B tier C
all right so in 2011 they they created
different sets of benefits they didn't
volunteers then that's a function of our
new computer system that went into
effect last year but they referred to
people who were
vested at the time the bill went into
effect which meant they had 10 years or
more
service that's tier and what was the
what was the date that was uh 112
I'm sorry 7
7111 two sets of dates
um so that's what we now call tier a
tier B are people who were hired before
11112 but did not have 10 years of
service so they were not vested so the
prior law you'll see speaks in terms of
vested by and not vested by and these
chain changes would slowly bring the
tier B people back to the tier a level
of benefits by changing that vested date
in a series of uh legislative changes
over the next 10
years um uh so that at that point
everyone will be back to the tier a
benefits they just have to wait until
their particular
year is changed so there's a little bit
of a a retention incentive because if
you're retired now you get the lower
benefits but if you wait until the Law
changes and for you it's going to change
in two years you might stick around and
get the higher
benefits now didn't yeah go ahead and
represent tierc of people hired honor
after 11
2012 Mr chairman yes go it might be
helpful when Marty was there last year
before the retirement commission he put
together a real like onepage sheet with
a c the dates the changes which would
certainly be very helpful I think to our
newer members because even though some
of us have been around here a long time
it's still confusing of course I think
if you Pi up or maybe make something new
but Marty put
together oh okay very good thanks
because we have 15 pages of this stuff
now didn't um the house build tube that
we passed two years ago from the house
didn't that help tier C's or not at all
no it didn't it was just tier B you one
of its first iterations it may have
included changing the earnable
compensation definition but that's not
what passed I see what passed was just
to
be that what passed the house what
passed the house was and then the from
the the final version is even less well
the final version didn't adopt of hb2 in
2023 did not adopt these sets of rules
Mr chair go ahead represent I believe
and representative leean would know
better than I do the Senate removed the
provisions that we're discussing and
they created a commission to look at
right to look at the issue they made the
recommendations and then there was a
bill
passed took care of the the bees but not
the C's but it was like a $26 million
charge to the general
fund
yeah but he says this is more for the
bees can I just add a little context to
that bill so all right Melissa
representative eel you're correct with
what you said hb2 House pass version
similar to this went to the senate
senate stripped it out created a
commission the following year in 2024
the house had HB
1647 that adjusted the multiplier for
tier B and tier C I think it was around
$56 million price tag it went to the
Senate the Senate felt that price tag
was too big with the budget that they
had so they removed the tier C portion
just the tier B multiplier was impacted
and that was a onetime 26
million um cost and that was last year
HB 1647 and did that affect both group
one and group two no this is all group
two
okay so uh that was increasing the
multiplier for years 16 and forward in a
career so not for your first 15 years
originally it was 10 years but then the
Senate they tacked on five more till the
final version that's what passed that's
what cost the 26 million
was if you work more than 15 years then
you multiply it goes up to two and a
half% per year for those years after
that all right so maybe as a task or I
don't know how hard this is but um if
you could get the House pass vers of
House Bill
1647 and
suppose we replaced this with that find
out what the cost of that
is but anyways keep going
with okay so um second part of this
summary discusses the cost differences
between the 2020 3 bill and the 2025
Bill uh we have the two actual
reports uh and those cost differences
attributable to several um factors one
is
uh current 2025 Bill appropriates $2
and5 million doll more a year for 10
years so that accounts for present value
of 25 million not a present value but
take that down to what the present value
is
um in between the two bills we had
changes in we
had Actuarial assumptions in in a new
experience study and so there were
different inflation wage growth
assumptions uh in the current valuation
versus the one done in
2023 and uh of course logically under
hb2 the benefit changes would have
started
earlier and so C that increases the cost
and there are fewer people in that tier
B now than there was when we priced it
out um and and we were using different
uh dates based on when legislation was
first submitted and what the most recent
valuation or closed uh um audited books
we had so from one from from
63022 to
63023 uh the number of trb people
reduced by
90 well that could be another 90 for the
year that's transpired since then we we
just don't have the Clos book numbers on
those uh so those are the factors that
taken together give you a difference in
cost in and if it draw your attention to
uh there are two actual reports one from
uh 2023
April 21st you turn to page 16 question
I don't be super dense here but where
did the 70 people go so now they so they
retired yeah or or they might have just
terminated or or some something else
they're just yeah tier B is yeah can't
get bigger can only get smaller get
smaller right yeah and and in general
when someone retires that's it they they
they unless there's is later their their
pension at that moment is fixed right so
yeah okay so in um you know as as as you
know there were different ways that we
measure costs and one is uh what is the
increase in the unfunded Actuarial crude
liabilities the other is what's the
impact on on um contribution rates for
the
employers um the 2023
Bill assuming the funding of 25 million
would have reduced the UA by 68.5
million the current bill for 2025 would
reduce it
by
98.2 so uh the current bill has a
has a more beneficial effect on the U
for the factors discussed in B one
through four of my
summary um in terms of contribution ions
in 2023 there
were nominal amounts of contribution
increases 64 to
75 100s of 1%
increase the the current bill for 2025
would actually show a a
3% difference in police reduction and a
0.03 increase for fire
um so again the 2025 bill is more
favorably compared to the other bill but
they're both not huge numbers uh and
both of these sets of numbers assume
that the Appropriations in the
legislation will be made for 10
years okay and so let's do have a number
if they're not made yeah well let's talk
about that because this says that we're
going to appropriate 27.5 million per
year right but what we see actually in
house bill one is only 5 million the
first year so do you know why that is no
I see the shaking
hands okay all right does
Melissa I think that was based on the
revenue um estimate from the governor
for the
VT uh revenue of
first year there's not enough coming in
the first year there's full amount is
coming in 27 so that's why it was only
so you haven't really analyzed it with a
22 and A5 million shortfall in the first
year of payments right we have not yeah
you haven't okay uh representative Ms
thank you uh and and please bear with me
because this is my my first rodeo here
um um so you know what what came first
the the decision on the am on the amount
that was going to be appropriated
or decisions about what the benefit
changes would
be it was all part of for this year what
now hb2 was HB
727 which was a piece of legislation
that came in with the benefit changes
and the appropriation in the bill as
like I guess I guess what I'm asking was
you know um did was
was I I guess what I'm trying to
understand is if you make changes to the
the benefit formula which I believe is
what is being proposed here that then
that then determines what the amount is
that you need to the additional amount
that you need to
fund right but we don't or you know was
that the process that went through or
did somebody say you know what we want
to give 25 million or $27.5
million they picked a number out of the
blue and said that's what we want to
contrib additionally we want to
contribute and then there and then we
kind of backed into what the formula was
going to be yeah no no I think there was
a set of benefit changes there have been
multiple attempts at this in the 13
years since the law first passed uh and
so people and the sponsors were quite
aware of what they were trying to
achieve benefit wise I would say and I
think the 275 was their best guess of
what it would cost based on past years
but we didn't put a dollar amount on it
until the bill was introduced and we got
a fiscal note worksheet request and it
turns out that the
275 if you're going to receive it is
more than you need to pay for the
changes to the tune of $98
million reduction in her un unfunded
account so that unfunded liability
that's interesting and I missed that I
guess so if I'm if I hear what you're
saying we could reduce the
275 by a certain amount without it
impacting the the desire
to um make the tier B people
whole it would be possible to back into
a number that said if it if the
appropriation is X then the UA would be
unchanged so neutral right now the
unfunded
liability would go
down 98.2 million and and I just excuse
me and and and I know that you know
everyone is very interested in reducing
the unfunded liability but we're already
on a we're already ready on a trajectory
to do that um do you have any
idea how much we could reduce the
275 buy and still maintain the desire to
levelize the benefits have to ask the
actu order of
magnitude five million 10 million like
to law school thing the teach is don't
mess with yeah that's that's that's
that's a good that's good advice have to
rely on the actual all right thank
you
um I think I can make a
guess but if you have an unfunded
liability of hundred million right the
um the payments on it
are we we assume 6 and a half% per year
that it's growing right so so to keep it
level if we paid in um six and a half
say it's 100 million right so if we paid
in six and a half million a year that
would unch the unfunded liability
wouldn't change I think right so so
that's kind of the number that I think
is um involved can I yeah can I can I
ask another question so I mean if if 275
is more than enough to cover the tier
two people could it also cover the tier
one without it having tier one didn't
have any benefit changes it didn't no oh
so we're just trying to get tier B I
think the the objective simply put is to
get tier B back to where tier eight okay
where they would have been which is I I
thought tier one was was impacted the
same way group one group one group one
that's what I'm sorry yeah thank
you yeah I ain't too good with the
English that once you go to group one
then your your your your Quantum of cost
is is way more because it's so much
larger okay much much no that that makes
sense much bigger so
how
um what does this bill change the
definition of final compensation in any
way yes yes it would eliminate for the
tier be people the current rule that
limits the compensation over base that
we count in calculating your average
final compensation for the purposes of
determining your benefit so we look at
the compensation over base which
is special Duty and overtime primarily
for group twos it would also include a
payout of um well it doesn't right now
under the new lot would um but so that
formula
is we look at your average comp over
base for your high five years that your
benefits calculated on and then we look
at the average over your whole career
and if the whole career average is lower
we limit what we count to that lower
percentage and this takes that away this
takes that away and then it also
redefines earnable
compensation so that it includes payout
of sick and vacation acrs at the time of
retirement I see so that is going to
boost your final that's spiking that um
no I
don't call term that people have
different meaning for so I'll stay away
from it uh it's way the way the law was
until 2011 we same you know some states
count base salary and nothing else we
count some right so from my point of
view this is very dangerous okay just
for you know discussion
purposes I'm I'm okay with changing
rates I mean the the um the multipliers
like we did in I guess according to
Melissa House Bill
1647 but changing the definition of
earnable
compensation and also
I think it's right the way it is all
right and
so this that allows a lot more game
playay and and things like that so this
is not something I I would care to go
with anyway go ahead represent M so so
um so what you're saying is these
changes to you know final average
compensation and all that good stuff
that just it gets everything back to the
way it was prior to 2011
we're basically putting back all of the
definitions that were in place then so
the three parts to it the definition of
earnable comp by bringing in acrs and
other things that were excluded yeah um
the change in the comp over base rule
for average final compensation as well
as changing the definition average final
compensation to High three not high five
so that's going to have oh that's in
here too that's in here too I see okay
so but all of that was was in place
prior that's to everyone had the same
benefits we're not we're not going we're
not which tier we're not creating some
new we're not going into new territory
no the intent was to restore okay not my
intent the sponsor's intent was to
restore The Tib people to where they
were prior to
2011 yeah but so in when we had this
rough budget year and maybe even rougher
than what we have this today
um in 2011 there was a whole bunch of
changes made to the retirement system
but the particular changes in the
definition of earnable compensation to
to reduce or eliminate
spiking I think were needed regardless
of what the budget was at the time right
so so what were what was fixed or
partially fixed by 1647 changing the
multiplier you know that you can argue
um was not justified and needed to be
restored and some of the kind of stuff
but but what people used to do with
their pension is sort of work all kinds
of overtime in the last couple of years
and and really boost it up because it
was only a three-year average now it's a
five-year average and and also this
other big part which is looking at the
overall average over the career right so
it's a little different somebody works
in Corrections right now and is working
40%
overtime constantly so for their whole
career you know it makes sense that
their pension gets much higher right but
somebody who only works in their final
few years a lot of overtime that doesn't
really make sense right and so that's
what those changes fixed and so to undo
those
things you know I think is wrong so we
we're going to have to look at this in
in a lot more detail did those represent
did those changes impact tier one t I'm
sorry I'm getting my group one no tier a
did they did no no so so TI still
maintained the
three-year yes threee and the definition
of arnal right because they were vested
right so yes okay
that makesense that Mak sense could take
yeah that makes sense right yeah okay so
you see what I mean at the time makes
sense so but but if we if we if the goal
is
to get the tier B back to where they
would have
been um and and equal to tier
a then we well by definition have to
make these changes if that's the goal
right and I would
argue
um that's not really the goal I mean our
goal is retention and and recruiting
right and so doing something for tier C
is more important but that's not but
that's not what the governor said in her
address well she the her goal was to
restore the benefits for The Tib people
fine but should that be the legislator's
goal
you know I would argue no but okay you
know um all right any other questions so
we're going to have to read all these
things and and digest them um any
other yeah all right some of us I guess
but but we do have some some uh we we
did ask the Edna committee about this
and they gave us a bunch of comments
some of which are questions so
um let's uh let's ask these detailed
questions so
um first of first response from medna so
they said um definition new definition
of
vested so so they say
um it's adds a new requirement that the
pension calculations shall not be
reduced after 3 years of service oh so
so
um let's look at so so this is in um
let's look at the page and House Bill
too yes repres could we get copies of
that I mean I had it on my
computer yeah it would great to follow
along with you yes all right so let's
look for this this is uh RSA 100a colon
one section
38 very first provision so that's on
page 25 yes okay so right so it's on
page
25 um section
25 okay line
27 um so shall not be reduced after
three years of service right so what
this is is a direction to Future
legislators don't change this
RSA all right so this has no effect
right because if if you want to tell
legislator something to do you got to
put it in the
Constitution you can't really put it in
the law and so you know I would tend to
say section 25 is
is has no
no serious effect precatory as we say
yeah okay all right so possibly we'll
we'll talk about removing that one but
um okay all right now next one
um the the um the next section no it's
um page 29 line 19 see she worked they
worked off of the old one so so our line
numbers are no longer yeah they're
working off HB 727 because that's the
bill that was in place when we committed
so this is um XV uh section
18 uh
XVI 17 that's a definition of earnable
compensation well it says deletes anti-s
spiking provision limiting extra and
special duty pay in the highest years to
average percentages over the
career uh well that's mixing two things
together
um that's that's see using the word
special duty but that's describing the
coov rule which is high high five
to total career average for special Duty
and overtime and anything else that
counts as comp over base the special
Duty rule which applies currently only
to tier a is if your average in your
high three is more than your average in
your high seven since the law passed in
2009 will limit you to the high seven so
there similar
objectives operate differently apply to
different
groups um this bill
would eliminate the compensation over
base rule for tier B and revert them to
the pre-existing rule that currently
applies to tier only which is just a
limit on special
Duty High three versus high seven for
average of seven right so what they're
saying is that what they're saying is
that it's making a change for tier
a well that's that's my point in a too
is was that intended or is that a scrier
eror I see I see because when you look
at it in the bill especially in hb2 it's
removed from the definition that would
be applicable to group one in the very
next section is the definition for group
two and I think someone just said wait
they forgot to put it in that section oh
this is your number two yeah because if
the intent of of this bill is to rectify
the tier B changes then why are they
changing the tier a law that existed
since prior to 2011 so I'm just deducing
it's a scrier there and that's what they
mean okay and our current valuation with
the actuary we told them to assume it
was a mistake and and can we notice
where in House Bill 2 that
is that
is at the bottom of page
25 let's see you right where the group
one definition ends
um for earnable
compensation so it would be
uh oh page 26 the crossed out section
yeah that's the cross down and then it
what it should have been is added to the
section I believe right after
that okay where it starts the uh I
believe it's lines five six and seven
section d i subsection D which would be
the the new definition it should go into
section
D which
is all right but anyways that's the
that's the um we'll point it out in the
fiscal note worksheet
okay okay so that's your number two
thing there okay so uh
nhrs number two okay the next thing they
say
is um the annuity multiplier for
creditable service changes but is not a
change um is not a change but its
current law it was passed in 2023 and
should have already been funded at that
time um sections 30 to 31
2.5 for the years in of 15
all so that speaking to the changes last
year that increased the multiplier to
2.5 for member um for members who work
more than 15 years so for years of
service higher than 15 so this bill is
going to eventually get everyone to 2.5
for their whole career so there's
there's overlap there
in that part of to the extent you're
working over 15 years and you're just
talking about the multiplier that part's
already been fixed last year and and
paid for with the 26
million
um so valuation by our act this year was
to
compare what this bill would do which
would give them the 2.5 for the years
one through
15 taking in consideration that the bill
last year already gave him 15 16 and and
over uh another reason that I didn't put
on this that I just thought of
why 25 Bill cost less than the 23 bill
because the 23 bill was restoring 2.5
for all years including over 15 because
HB 1647 hadn't passed yet so in 23 so
that's another reason that accounts for
why 23 was more
expensive by because current law has
changed law on the inter change and has
already fixed the multiplier for year 16
I right right right so this is changing
the multiplier for years below 50
effectively yes doesn't say that but
effectively that's the I I see okay good
okay representative M yes so that meliss
um what Mr kavana was just speaking of
that would be the one comparison I think
that's similar to
1647 house past version
right in the sense that it was they
wanted to do 10 years in the House pass
version um but what was passed by the
Senate was 15 correct so they increased
it ah so you had asked what the diff
this compared to 1647 house passed was
and that's the area in that area yeah
yeah yeah now did House Bill 1647 affect
Group C I mean tier C or no so the House
pass version did 10 10 years for the
multiplier 10 years forward it adjusted
the multiplier to half% and it did tier
B and tier C what passed was 15 years
for tier B only gotcha and that was the
that price difference from the 53
million to the 26 million noted on the
last sheet of paper that I just handed
out but okay um just for comparison
that's the only overlap I believe that's
in hb2 as you see compared to 1647 mhmh
the rest is all different
than 1647 now on your paper when you say
UA impact is that a one time or is I
guess that is a one time right yeah
that's uh that element of the cost
estimate is how much it goes up or down
for benefits that are or are not funded
at the time of the legislation I see the
other cost aspect are the the impact on
contributions which are going to be
ongoing every year
right I see so so this is a good
opportunity to go back and revisit this
house bill
1647 um and put
it put the force of House Bill 2 behind
it right as opposed to
okay yeah well I mean there's already
the
money in is some money for it I mean
anyway okay good so the next thing they
say is um I guess that's it for retire
for
this right now there were there's a
couple of other Provisions in House Bill
2 that are about
retirement um so let me look for those 1
150 and
151 which deal with reclassification of
a couple of positions at
safety one for
hazardous waste something or other and
the other for Deputy policy person okay
why don't that's actually not on our
list oh uh because we're that's group
two that's division two um but we might
as well talk about them since it's if
it's involves
you um but no I was thinking about um
section 142 on page
62 which dates what I don't have it says
that accounting unit 1051 is
non-aps don't don't know what that
means okay but it's titled New Hampshire
retirement
system correct
but okay do we know what Accounting in
at 1051 budget line is counting unit
1051 well look if you want to just give
us a
second
okay so that looks like it's the
administration of the New Hampshire
retirement
system okay General administrative
budget what is what it is okay so I
think sorry we're we're catching up a
little bit so I'm assuming Mr chair that
is where that appropri appropriation
is I'm going to quote appropriation for
the V for this retirement hb2 retirement
um monies so I'm assuming putting that
in there so it doesn't because they
added it the five and the 28 or whatever
they don't want it to lapse out I get it
okay so it is related I guess okay and I
would just point out again I think I
said it in the last meeting um the
language or the the money for this bill
show up in two places they show up in
hb1 under that accounting unit for 1051
which is on the page 155 and
156 of hb1 and then they also show up it
also shows up in hb2 so it is pulling
twice so as the division we do need to
remove it preferably probably from hb1
this isn't one that's typically in hp1
the appropriation would be in hb2 so we
just need to make sure we do remove
those okay all right and then and this
language if we take it out of one and
there's the whole connection to the
lottery business right you know so
that's so Mr cin I and I were speaking
of this yesterday so there's a finding
in HB uh to where the appropriation Jack
got page um that
says the the governor the legislature
will want to use BLT Revenue to pay for
the retirement however within the bill
the appropriation is coming from the
general fund so there is no tie to the
VT Revenue to the retirement payment
except to the extent that 45 um a
certain percentage I don't want to say
45% if that's not right a certain
percentage of the BLT Revenue will flow
to the general fund and then I think the
assumption is that money then flows
through the retirement but there is
nothing in law that's stating the VT
Revenue will pay for the retirement
there's just a finding statement which
um statement of intent whoever said it
yes statement of intent if that's
helpful okay I get it but um I I can
just tell you that the plans of division
two are to take any VT Revenue if there
is any and put it in the education trust
fund just so that there's no argument
about you know Lottery money not going
to to education right and then they're
going to adjust other monies going into
the education trust fund to make it come
out right so yeah so to that point if
that was done that still would not
impact this retirement funding because
the appropriation just says just say
general f okay we've assumed the number
will be zero that we receive from vat
okay and then you wouldn't need this
non-lps
thing right so so so this
33 million or something is
it I think yes in one level uh on the
second level I think the numbers that
you've already received from Mike Kane
already removed that devil counting oh
okay well we'll see all right um the the
other one let's see to talk
about
um yeah hold on a second
where's my
um one ah here it
is so
um uh section 177 on page
72 okay there's a couple of sections of
House Bill 2 that strike me as a really
big deal you know the the executive
brand kind of grabbing a a whole bunch
of power that we don't normally give
them and so um this is one of them and
this
is um section
177 on page
72 so it it says here after exhausting
any relevant appeal process state
agencies may use
funds um from an existing class 60 or
any other Pro apprpriate budget class to
pay penalties fines interests or other
costs imposed on the state of New
Hampshire by the New Hampshire
retirement system or by the IRS relating
to employer payments reporting and
audits so do you know what this is about
penalties fines and interests and other
costs imposed by the New Hampshire
describe what kind of penalties cost and
interests we impose for employers I
don't know what was intended by putting
that in or the IRS I mean is the IRS
well the
IRS I have my Ms along law taxation but
I can't speak for the IR yeah right okay
they have trouble speaking for
themselves gotcha so our employers are
required to report every month and if
they're late we can assess a
penalty 1% pen
if
they withhold money from a paycheck and
forget to give it to us they could pay
one% per month penalty
interest anytime they pay something late
it's just regular
interest so if we were to discover on
audit that they forgot entirely to even
report or withheld hold from someone's
then we would say okay here's what you
should have withheld and we would build
a member for that with interest and we'd
build the employer for their share of
the contribution with interest so uh
that's that's those are the penalties in
there's also uh penalties daily
penalties of 25 or
$250 a day for not reporting information
they're supposed to report to us that
was uh intended the interest and other
penalties are more for economic reasons
time value of money these daily ones are
kind of a sword to make you do because
we had employers who just were ignoring
our requests for information so one
applies to retire reporting other
replies to applies to just general
request for information like when we're
doing an audit but is the state as an
employer are they being getting are they
getting these kind of penalties and
fines um I mean I can see interest maybe
if it's yeah yeah well we work closely
with with uh Das payroll and Carolyn
Boyd and her staff to avoid penalties
and and it it's not common that we would
charge them a penalty they have a they
have a fairly sophisticated centralized
payroll system and and they do a good
job at that so um occasionally when
they're late you know we we'll
wave the the penalty or interest because
it it was late by a week for some reason
uh that's reasonable I see there there
is a reasonable good cause exception um
where we see more penalty in interest
with small political unsophisticated
political subdivision employers who just
don't have the staff or that's what I
would think anyway representative rang
did you have a question he just oh okay
good so
um I guess from your point of view
having this particular
section doesn't really yeah it's just
okay just who pays us yeah it's I I
viewed it that's just an accounting
thing so Melissa do we have a way of
asking the governor's office why they
put this particular one
in y we can ask them we've sent a couple
out already to um commissioner Arling
house and CC the governor's office so
this will be one of them that will put
in there as well good all right um do we
know of anything else related to
retirement just the two position changes
I just wanted to mention them there oh
yes um there are two positions at safety
that they wanted to allow a member a
person who took that position to be in
group two if they were coming from a
group two position or were a group two
retiree and they wanted to take this job
and maintain group two level benefits
because one of them's a policy position
and the other one's a hazardous
management hazardous waste management
type position and neither one of neither
one of them qualified for the the the
core definition of group two because
then not exposed to the hazards of
firefighting or police work I you're
saying so and the policy position is
optional so that could if that's a
retire he's not going to opt in he's
going to take the pension and the pay
the other position is mandatory but if
it's someone coming from a group to
position or someone who had retired from
a group two position they would be
required to join but they could be a
group two member that means for that
person's salary the state's going to pay
the higher group to employer rate
but you're only talking about one
position one salary I understand tell me
the the sections again 150 and 151 so
it's on page
63 63 starts at the bottom the last send
is on the bottom and then it goes to
okay okay division of fire
safety so
I see so this is this is a
recruitment yeah yeah based thing and
it's similar for instance to um group
two firefighters who go to work as
instructors at the uh fire academy
they're allowed to stay in group too
even though they're not out getting on
Tru and fight fires regularly MH um and
the same thing for the for the police
academy police standards there a similar
rule it says if you're coming from group
two you can stay in group two even
though this really isn't so this is
section 152 on page
64 yeah that's that's the the the second
P it's um second uh chief of policy and
planning yes yes yeah
um as long ases six seven years ago they
were ask
that group to and I said it takes
legislation so I think it is finally
getting around all right represent thank
you Mr chair so on that position so what
I'm reading is that if the person
retired in group two okay so they're on
retirement they can come into this
position as a group two now how does
that affect their retirement benefits it
would stop okay so they'd stop receiving
retirement and then would acrew but they
addition service credit and then re
retire based on the new length of
service so okay so so so that retirement
from their pre first group two position
ends they assume the full-time position
it know it it actually doesn't even have
to be full-time right uh no it has to be
oh okay so it has to group two
definition is fulltime so they they now
start this new position and they still
have to acrw the vested years or is that
credited or it's just the benefit amount
it's we treat has a small break and
serve active service for okay so you
everything that you did before is still
on your record I got you and then we
just add additional service so one of
these positions is mandatory so if
someone took that position they'd have
to join and if they were a retiree the
pension would stop the other Poli policy
position I believe is not mandatory it's
optional and therefore that person could
um decide to keep the receiving their
pension and their salary so it's it's
it's a little bit different in an
optional position because most of the
state's optional positions are officials
appointed for fixed terms where the term
is expressed in in an enabling statute
that the governor nominates and and the
executive Council uh um
approves and the person can only be
removed for cause under the after a
hearing through the executive counil
this position just
gives Department of fire safety ability
to hire that person at a ra employee and
make them exempt without the fixed term
officials and fixed term officials are
your Commissioners you Commissioners you
know are both of these positions
unclassified or not I believe they state
that they're one is UN I believe it
states that they're unclassified okay at
the beginning but some unclass the first
one classified I'm sorry so you're
saying that for some unclassified
positions participation in the
retirement system is optional right but
classified but for some it's not correct
majority of unclassified well no
unclassified if you're not collecting
the pension
unclassified is optional okay once you
start collecting the pension it's only
optional if you're a fixed term official
I see what you're saying so okay young
people who are in unclassified positions
have the choice do I want to join or do
I not and according to my discussions of
dop about 90% do join
okay um even though they don't have to
maybe they came from other departments
or they have other governmental Services
they want to keep it going right and
okay um what happens to a a retired
group two member who takes a full-time
job that's group one well then they
would
retire when ending that group one
position yeah as a group one
retiree we would calculate their benefit
in two parts the group two part based on
the multipliers and the years of service
in the group one p we combine them but
the big difference is under our
administrative rules uh it states that
when you are a split benefit and that's
what we call these people you receive
any ancillary
benefits that are applicable to the
group you're in when you retire so for a
group two the main thing is under RSA
a12 where they get a 50% survivorship
annuity for their spouse that they don't
have to pay for so if you're split
benefit your group two and then you
retire in group one you lose that free
benefit and you have to now if you want
to give that 50% to your wife you can
now pay for it most group twos they pay
for 50 and they get the other 50 for
free uh the one you pay for is under a13
one that's free is under a12 um that's 5
to 7 % reduction in your maximum benefit
to pay for that
50% um and and so it's significant you'd
also lose the medical subsidy benefit if
you were eligible for it but there were
fewer and fewer people eligible for that
because you had to be in group one on
June 30th 2000 so you know almost 25
years ago so there are some people there
are you know quite a few but it's it's
so there's a big disincentive for people
to do what we just talk about yes well
the other rule the other thing is that
um the coob rule for group twos Compares
high five to whole career for group ones
it Compares high five to rest of career
so if you're spiking it's not rolling
those numbers into the rest of the
career Gap understand so we we have a a
real example where uh uh a group two did
a lot of overtime towards the end of his
career the haircut under the and then he
he um he took a group two job a group
one job for a couple of months so we
said well the group one formula that
formula allowed 25% of all that overtime
to be counted the group two formula
would have allowed
65% so that is another significant
difference if you are if the if if
you're implicated by the cob rule by a
lot of overtime or special duty at the
end of your
career so those are the three impacts of
okay
that sounds like something more
complicated than we can fix in the
budget okay do you know what the cost of
these two sections is for these two
particular
people di Minimus it's I see it's a
different the state will be paying the
group two employer rate of I think what
31% versus the group one employer rate
of
17 14 14 I don't know what the top of my
head but um 14 maybe or something yeah
so the state's going to pay a little
more on the employer contributions for
that those two positions whatever that
salary is okay and and and the member
would also pay P the higher member
contributions 11.5 versus 7 I see I see
um but in terms of cost of the state
you're just looking at the differential
in the contribution rates for those two
positions what they're pay
yeah but it's 10% or something for no
yeah yeah okay all right it makes some
all
right
great any other things we can
think no no all right thank you very
much thank you thank you all right yeah
represent M okay um just one question um
how long is it how long does it take for
you to do a an Actuarial Actuarial
estimate of um you know kind of a a
final final formula that we may come up
with you about a week's turnaround okay
with the actuary I there have been other
times where we've rushed it through
because legislature had deadlines to
meet and last minute changes especially
on the floor oh can you do this
overnight sometimes if it's a minor
change you know if they're got to do a
full evaluation that's going to take
them long yeah and and the real Focus I
think would be you know if we made any
changes to what's being proposed in
terms of the the formula what would the
annual uh contribution requirement for
last year when when when HB 647 went
over to the Senate and everyone's you
know hesitated at the price tag we did a
supplemental valuation with the lower
benefit amounts and and that was
performed fairly quickly but depends the
cont typically it's it's a
week yeah and we and we'd also need to
have a copy of the amendment so we can
give that provide that to the actuary so
representative Ms I just want to clarify
a couple of things so for any Actuarial
analysis that goes to the
retirement um per the law has to be an
amendment because we actually they bill
us for that cost of because they ship it
out to an actuary so they B the
legislature for the cost of those so it
what goes to them can't just be an email
or can't just be what if what if it has
to be an official Amendment just because
of the cost is
paid no no no
hypotheticals
okay um we're done yeah thank you thank
you very
much um so we want to continue continue
with House Bill 2 things I was thinking
maybe we could just keep going with the
Edna comments while we while we're on
them um the the next one
is
um section 10 Board of tax and land
appeals um these things uh just just
seem
like reasonably good
ideas um so we're on page let
see 42 and
43 yeah so I mean this is
um a little bit of of flexibility in
hiring and um all so on how that they
can can conduct hearings by U electronic
means right so I don't see anything any
big deal with
those so when they came in they were
having trouble hiring an appraiser yeah
because the private sector was offering
more so that was changing that
yeah any any objections to these
sections
no okay whether we keep them or not as a
whole is another question right but
yeah that was my next question are we
are we taking a vote on it or we just
moving forward yeah I mean so for for
the time being I I I would say um keep
these sections if if we're going to keep
the agency but
okay any and I don't see any objections
to that right so okay um the next thing
on the list
was
um administrative Services um section
which
um uh Bridges house okay so where's the
that's
um I saw it here
brid's
house is on page
[Music]
71 Bridge's house is it's essentially
the governor's
mansion but nobody lives there
right they they sometimes have events
there and things like that yeah
um okay and so
um
so um just makes the fund for
maintenance of bridges house
non-aps and and allows the governor to
accept um grants and so on
seems
okay any any issues okay so we'll keep
keep that section where is it
here Bridges has keep yes represent run
so there's no appropriation with that
section it's just allowing the it makes
it non-aps yes and so there's already a
fund okay I mean I guess we could if we
wanted to we could go look up you know
what's the balance of that fund
but I don't know it's in general I would
think since we already have I mean funds
are not necessarily lapsing just because
they're there so can I yes go ah
clarification so this this fund is
already non-aps yeah um it's not
changing that it's just continuing
approprate to the Department of
administrative services so it's just
giving them the authority I'm not sure
where it lands at this point um I'm
assuming that they probably already
have access to that Jack just looked up
the dedicated fund and it shows no
dollars in there currently in the
administrative Services is the agency
that's um in charge of the fund so I
think it's just a clarification this
just clean up housekeeping okay so
there's no real change that this is
doing okay that's
yeah all right represent do we need a
vote to to say we keeping this section
or we can I just wanted brid's house yes
did you want to do an amendment to
capitalize Bridge's house per Edna's
recommendation or are you fine with
keeping it the same what's that Bridges
house because it's
a
oh where is it on line seven oh I see on
line
four page 71 so line four and line seven
on page 71 okay
it appears twice on line seven yes yes
yes yes yes okay I like that suggestion
okay and twice on line so yeah I see so
what you can do is um you can take a
vote to keep the section with the
amendment that will capitalize those
those three places those three
references right all right should we do
that I move that we make those changes
okay I'll in favor yeah second it yeah
second by representative EV okay good so
that's a simple
one
yeah okay um page uh section the next
section audit set aside so what she says
is
uh right she doesn't understand why we
want to um wave these audits set aside
so they don't like this I guess so I
have some information on this
like uh so we reached out to edmin
services on this and apparently when
arpa monies were coming through they
were struggling to do the audit set
aside with the past arpa monies and
there was it was getting a little messy
very rare situation because it was all
these arpa dollars and now those are not
coming in so this was only for that
particular situation and it's very rare
So admin Services was fine either way
either keep it as it or put this into
statute so they have the ability to wave
it if these rare circumstances come up
it doesn't necessarily Define those rare
circumstances so it gives them a little
bit more Authority than they would have
had prior but if you're
comfortable that's what the request is
but admin Services took no position on
it one way or
another well obviously they asked for it
in the first place because that's why
it's here right so that's true they came
up with this when they were dealing with
the arpa stuff but now that the arpa
stuff has passed I
see so they said they're good either way
represent R um I'm um of the mind to
just delete this just because I think
some of the terminology is vague like
State objectives you know it would
really be up it's a very subjective
determination and leaving that to just
one person I feel isn't in the best
interest of the state to have that vague
language yeah and it seems like Edna
didn't like it so and it also seems
since it is such a rare occurrence I
don't think we're going to see any
impact of deleting that on the function
of the state okay so you want to move uh
to remove section
174 yes I move that we remove one
section 174 from hb2 I'm on a roll here
this is like my second motion all right
seconded by representative camell all
those in favor I okay good so remove
that
one okay next one uh section
176 uh also on the same
page they say uh we don't see a problem
with limiting the Surplus distribution
fund to three months operation and and
making it
non-aps so they they're okay with this
one um
I
guess I'm not sure about
non-aps does this fund
provide is there is there sort of a
limit to what's in this fund
or let's look up how much money is in
this one
they are deleting it I mean they are
reducing it from three from six months
operations to three
months right
looking up page um
71 yeah 176
yeah yeah see this is one of those
things where we only see part of the law
right because there's a colon at the
bottom of page 71 and we're not seeing
like what's coming after that I
think so representative Maguire um
currently in that account there's
$539,000 and generally generally around
that it looked like in 21 and
22 was about 200,000 and then it went to
400 in the last two years it's been
about 500,000 5 how much so expenses are
about 300 to 400,000 a year I see
okay
um all
right and it's it the funds come from
fees assessed for handling Surplus
assets okay and this non-lps part it
wouldn't normally lapse right
it appears looking at the fund that it
doesn't lapse because there's a
beginning balance it's not starting at
zero every time so I'm not sure about
that but we can look into that with
admin Services if you like yeah I mean
they're probably just confirming in
statute what the
actual experience is could be all right
but I'll I'll let me look this up just
to okay so this is number
176 176 yeah all right so look up they
did
recommend okay I you want to just accept
it let just accept it yeah accept it
accept it okay make a motion to accept
all right I'll second it okay all in
favor yes all right good all right we'll
just move on from this one okay next one
is section one
ah this is the one we just talked
about so yeah we're going to get some
more information from them as to why
they want this to me this sounds like a
big deal right um use money from any
budget class you know this this lets
people bypass the the fiscal committee
basically right when they want to move
money around for all kinds of purposes
so I this one I don't care
for but yes represent R well is there an
issue with this because if they're using
another class to pay penalties and fines
how would we track how many penalties
and fines have been levied to me it's if
they should have a class where if we
want to find out okay you know were
there issues with those state agencies
and in withholding retirement
contributions or retirement uh premiums
so yeah you know I'd want to be able to
look and say okay here oh my gosh this
agency was fined x amount yeah but if
they're able to pay that from different
classes I'm not sure how easily it would
be to determine what those fines and
penalties were yeah that's just to me it
reads way too broad but we'll we'll get
some some
information uh from the governor's
office so let's skip this
one
um okay
this one starts at the bottom of the
last line of page
73 section 1899 y yeah
mechanical so for this one this is a uh
This falls under division two yeah okay
yes
so okay so but I'll tell you the it's
it's oplc right so that's why we
they looked at it um but you should tell
division 2 that there's no money coming
with these nine people right so they
Edna likes the idea of moving it and
says it should have been done before
it's an oversight that it wasn't right
but because these people are not really
doing licensing but they work for oplc
that's the issue but
but so everybody agrees they should be
moved right but but there's no money to
pay and they are um they actually
already show up in hb1 in safety's
budget okay good division is aware of
that so so these are good sections all
right and then barbering and cosmetology
so those are the last Parts page
um starts on page 74 line
right okay wording changes to maintain
sanitation
um
uh okay so we're going to wait for for
oplc to to provide better language okay
yeah okay all right so this is a weight
here
wait or OPC
okay
20 what's that
203 yep oh 203 repealing the apprentices
to provide their social security number
okay
necessary it violates federal law yeah
that sounds like a good thing to do go
back 174 you want to reconsider
be clear okay okay can we don't use
those funds how do we get them
over can we vote on 203 though that's
when I think in
the just a moment representative Griffin
so we're we're currently talking about
203 right let's let's get that out of
the way so I'd like to move to uh follow
the instruction of Edna and repeal as
indicated
except section 203 except whatever the
language is okay except 203 you okay yep
okay y okay second by representative
camell all in favor yes back to
unanimous all right now representative
Griffin wants to rec talk about section
174 if you get a f Federal Grant and
they decide not to a time goes back how
do you free those funds
up some of the youth that's what I think
all we could ask so um we have an answer
from them for part of that so what the
intent of this language
was was that when the arpa funds came
through there wasn't an audit set aside
requirement for those funds so what they
did instead because there was wasn't the
audit set aside fund was sort of flush
so instead they waved the right to
collect the audit fee on those so they
were putting that into law that they
could wave that right in that small
particular situation with the arpa funds
typically they do have language to set
aside the 1% for the audit set aside or
the 0.1% for the audit set aside so
every every Federal audit that comes
down through the dollars are there and
they will be collected to your question
I don't know if there's ever extra funds
in there because there is the audit
isn't pulled from it but B reading das's
email where they said the account was
flush I'm assuming those are getting
used up and paid back for instance LBA
when we do an audit of better funds like
the the money gets transferred back to
us for that
1% of those audit that decide funds
that's probably conflating issue a
little
bit so just to restate it maybe in a
different
way this small particular circumstance
happened because all of that money
flooded in from the federal government
without audit set aside requirements so
the 1% was not collected on those funds
there was no extra dollars to collect
those funds so instead Das waved that
requirement to collect on those funds
they want to put this in statute so they
could do that again or they could
collect on it but it's a very small
circumstance that may never arise again
so it does seem like they have an option
if they need an option because they used
it last time but I think they were
trying to put it in statute for clarity
because they ran into an issue does that
answer the question on some level does
this 1% set aside for audits is it
always exactly 1% or it up to 1% cuz
what you sounded like was the fund is
flush meaning you know the one all the
1% are more than
necessary there is some variations
typically it's 1% I do know because
you'll see this on fiscal items there'll
be a line that says audit uh audit set
aside when they're receiving fiscal um
money for federal
grants I do know we've questioned it a
couple of times because it's been
different in particular um Department of
Business and economic Affairs they have
a different audit set aside amount for a
particular situation I don't remember
what that amount is but I would say 95%
of the time it's that 1% yeah because I
mean the important thing is to have the
audit
done right not that it's I mean maybe
certain audit only takes half a percent
or something right
so it's fair yeah all right but if but
that's maybe federal law that it's one
that's what I'm thinking and I can look
into that and yeah because if especially
since they said the arpa funds didn't
have the federal requirement right right
but if it's New Hampshire law that it's
exactly 1% we might want to change it to
up to 1% or something like that yeah we
can look into that for you okay we did
vote on that item though we did yes we
voted to not accept Section
174 yeah okay
next one let's see where how are we
doing we still got plenty of time okay
now as long as we're um there are a
couple other of these kind of things
that I marked as a big deal let's go to
page
70 and by the way I haven't I've only
heard from Edna I have not heard from
any other committee that got pages so I
may have to poke some of them
um section
170 not withstanding any other provision
of law to the contrary any executive dep
Branch department or agency may fill
unfunded positions during the bium
provided that total expenditures for
such positions shall not exceed the
amount
appropriated for personnel and
benefits so
um is this a standard item or is this
no this is a new request that's come in
um I think when we had agencies come in
I think Department of Revenue was one
there was another agency that was asking
for this ability I think Corrections
already has this ability so this um was
making it for all executive branches and
it wouldn't be a cost in the sense that
when they're trans ing the amount is
flush but it just allows them to fill a
position more quickly or or maybe
someone left I I believe the example
they gave was somebody left they no
longer needed that position in
particular but they had a lower grade
position that they wanted to be able to
fill instead and this would allow them
sort of to be more fluid to higher
positions when someone leaves yeah I
mean represent yeah I was just going to
say it strikes me that this is a
provision that allows for better
management within the agency because if
someone leaves they can make yeah I
mean
right well not exactly right because
they get their lapses from unfunded
positions well they get their lapses
from unused Personnel money right so um
to the extent that they can spend faster
or more
there'll be less lapses fewer lapses so
um I mean I guess part of it is that
just because it's unfunded it doesn't
mean that it might not be vital and they
might find over time that a need arises
that they didn't anticipate or something
and I just think from an agency
standpoint point it makes for better
management
capabilities
okay I agree don't you think you're the
man you're a manager
mean yeah yes I would make a motion to
to accept that I'll second it okay any
any more discussion no because so what
this tells us is if we really don't want
to spend on a position we have to
eliminate the
position right so then it won't be a
position anymore right so there's a
whole lot of unfunded positions right
there's there's something like 20,000
positions but 's only 14,000 people
working or something like that right so
so if we really don't want a position to
be there then we have to eliminate the
position okay all right but we can vote
on this if you want yeah yeah okay all
in
favor okay I'll be
against the motion passes all right so
we're going to keep section 170
all
right now uh next one is similar let's
see
um
172 so wait why why is 171 on our list
highways and other public
works yeah Das
oh is that what it is it's not high
do
171 we're 17 oh I was reading 172 yeah
we're going to go there in a minute I
just as long as we were here I said
highways and that's on our list so I
would think that might be do
it's the same management argument I see
right I mean and also this 50,000 was
probably set a century ago so they're
trying to up the up the ante oh so this
is changing what has to go to governor
and Council yes that's it I was just
going to say it falls under uh division
one because it's sort of legislative
executive branch gotcha it's so the
title's a little misleading but it's any
administration of Federal Aid that goes
to GNC so I'd like to wait on this one
until we hear from representative wer um
and also we can research when was the
$50,000 set because this is yet another
big deal right I mean this is
uh changing what goes to governor and
Council Mr
chairman change that long ago I would
say we should leave it at 50
personally okay I think $100,000 still a
lot of money even though we deal with
Millions
right so you'd like you like it as is
without this section but but I think
this just applies in the case of Federal
Aid I don't know I'm not sure we've read
it completely anyway yeah let's I I'll
ask let's get a reaction
from
um
assistance highways and other public
work it's for federal benefits
facilities Grant AIDS or other Federal
Appropriations or Services made
available to assist theate activity
right it's just being able it's just not
in the case of State money expenditures
I think it's just facilitating easier uh
time with fed Federal monies yeah
because right now they can't if they
they can apply they can apply and
receive a a Federal grant but if it's
over 50,000 they have to go to governor
and Council to expend right I'm I'm kind
of of the mind to accept this and go to
100,000 because I think it would um
assist in the execution of projects or
the implementation of projects speed
them up yeah I mean if if you look at
just uh grants that Dees gets from the
also the fiscal committee too oh is it
oh
great so I like I said I let let's wait
and and see what represented wer think
representative Maguire uh Jack just
looked it up the 50,000 was set in 2005
in House Bill two okay so it's 20 years
20 it's 20 I know I just think it'd be
more efficient and cost effective
because it's such a timesaver to just
allow agencies to manage that money
without having to jump through all those
Hoops yeah okay well we'll we'll we'll
come back to this one 100,000 isn't set
in stone either you could do
75 that's true true yeah I just like I'd
like a little more input okay well let's
go to 172 okay excuse me Mr before we
move on um if I could ask Melissa if you
and Jack if you could find find um or
get an estimate of how many times um
agencies have had to go to get 50,000
approved over 50,000 I'd be interested
to see what type of
work9 that's what I was just going to
clarify okay like for every 50,000 they
have to go but do you mean that that
Delta between 50 I mean are we talking
about 200 grants or are we talking about
20 right I mean does this make the
fiscal committee do half the work
they're doing
now or something huh yeah well one of
the things the fiscal committee also
does when they look at these grants is
to see if there's any sort of language
that obligates the Departments to fund
it going forward and this and it just
makes us look further and $50,000 still
seems like even to me a lot of money but
it does require you know more oversite
more transparency you push it up
$100,000 you may find that people come
in
uh less often but what's going on with
the money with the grants being accepted
because there are requirements about
Audits and this money any federal money
that we get there is a requirement for
audits so I just think it's worked well
at 50 and gotta my opinion I know
Jerry's on fiscal too whether you want
us a comment
but okay representative McGuire just had
one question actually for representative
Lehman um we're looking it up now but is
fiscal currently 100,000 it is so this
is GNC it seems like they're matching
GNC to match fiscal yeah oh I see so it
seems like GNC probably has this little
area of 50,000 to 100,000 that only
they're having to approve fiscal only
comes to 100,000 and up but this is
differentation but it's GNC I think it's
GNC and fiscal because it says with
prior approval of the joint fiscal
committee Ze yeah so if it's prior
approval of the fiscal committee the
fiscal committee would have only looked
at it for a 100 right so they're oh so
you think this is fixing aing it's
really conforming
language all right well let let's let's
make
sure yes I I think so too okay let's go
to the
172 oh I see it's 100,000 in here too
yeah
so
um authorized to transfer every
Department as defined by RSA 9on
1 whatever that is it's probably every
department is authorized to tra transfer
funds among all accounting
units with the approval of the
commissioner of
Das um so that's osing the commissioner
right but the other language isn't
changing so it's actually tightening it
up yes right so this is making more work
for
Charlie but Charlie must have had some
input on it what you think I would guess
is that is that really necessary I mean
you know that that the commissioner of
the Department of Environmental Services
needs to go to the commissioner of admin
services to get his
approval yeah I
mean we can check with admin services on
this one typically all fiscal items
before coming to fiscal do go through
admin Services their business
supervisors review all of their items
they work with the agencies on it they
make sure it's correct um but we can
check with Charlie to see if it's it
could be that maybe they want to be able
to kick them back when they're receiving
them that they're not an accurate
request is that but the current
procedure that's if I'm reading this
right does that apply only to U
transfers of over
$100,000 are you saying every single
transfer has to be review over every
every item that goes to fiscal so over
the 100,000 goes through admin Services
first but this is if I'm reading this
right this is I want to move $20 yes
right that's my point if I read it
correctly it says any transfer has to be
approved by the commissioner of
administrative services
and then it says provided that anything
over 100,000 has to go to fiscal yeah
this doesn't look that great to me seems
we can look into that it
just yeah
Petty well he'll he's gonna come in for
some other things I imagine so we can
ask
him
um
piy yeah we don't want to make work
where it's not necessary okay all right
should we go back to the front
maybe um did we do everything on the
back oh Capital project overview
committee um
175 yeah so page 71 I actually have been
trying to figure this out because you re
remember that we um so um there's a
thing called the capital project
overview committee it used to be the
capital uh budget overview committee and
we changed it to project because a lot
because capital projects were ending up
coming through the operating budget and
they weren't really subject to any
oversight at all um like you know for
instance the women's prison went through
the operating budget at one or there was
some other large thing I forget anyway
so we amended that but the thing is
there's still all these references to
the C capital budget in here and so I
talked to chis Shay and I just um wanted
to look once more at the use of the
phrase capital budget in here and
whether we should just also be deleting
the words budget otherwise I think it's
fine I just was trying to figure out if
we want to clean it up a little more Mr
chair I see so what you're saying is
um capital projects rather than capital
budget projects right because the
capital budget implies it came through
the capital budget but when you have a
capital project that comes through the
operating budget it should be still
reviewed by the this committee I but I I
know but I want I just I wanted to
double check it once more with Chris
because I told him I would okay all
right all right thank you okay so we'll
come back to this one but that does
sound reasonable yeah okay and the rest
of the stuff is just changing timing
yeah yeah I mean otherwise it's changing
quarterly to annually yeah otherwise
it's it's pretty much fine but I'm going
to let me look at it once more okay okay
all very good are you a member of this
committee I am okay very good and I also
have like you know because of my Public
Works background I have an interest in
it in this particular one okay so we
will wait for representative eil on this
one all right so wait
section is that it's section 175 on page
71 okay all right so why I just interrup
go ahead Melissa you might want to talk
to chish because I feel like we talked
about this in the capital project
overview committee and they weren't that
excited about going to an annual report
yes I trying to remember what that was
yeah okay so
um let's go to page
73 um Canon
Mountain but they said something about
this
right $18
million
um yeah what the what I thought she said
was that it was um being lapsing was
being lapsed back to the general fund
but when I'm reading this it looks like
they can use some of it for um
maintenance yeah so it wasn't but maybe
Melissa and Jack have a thought on this
because if it's just lapsing back it's
certainly a good
thing well I thought we wanted to keep
it for the project right
um actually they they did did some
switching around and there's also the
thing is there's $20 million in the
capital budget for the
tram I'm trying to remember what she
said right so we need to see what the
original language is that's being
changed right that's
the so this is from houseu 2 two years
ago right correct so how I'm reading
this is that the 18 million whatever is
not spent will just go back to the
general fund right except she could use
part of it for maintenance no I think
they didn't they didn't do the project
this is when she was talking about
learning from
the I don't know how many how many
concrete peers they would need and I
don't know she was saying all kinds of
stuff my my notes my notes from her
testimony were that the um the 18
million will revert back to the general
fund in 2425
right and that 20 million for the
Tramway would be included in the capital
budget for 26
okay all right so
then I I I I mean can you see anything
that would be clarifying Melissa because
otherwise I'd be happy to make a
motion I'm just want to look it up right
now just to make sure let's find out
what what the
original um what are we changing from it
was 18 million yeah but the amount was
right I just was looking at I'm it's
probably the last sentence is new I'm
guessing right yeah that's that's
correct right I'm looking at it right
now so it was the 18 million it's the
lapse
amount any remaining funds hereby
appropriated shall lapse to the general
fund on July 1 2025 yeah I think I think
she's giving it back and replacing the
money with the capital bud appropriation
correct so the original 18 million was
um non-lps so that money would just sit
in their fund Forever This is allowing
that money to lapse back to the general
fund so they can use it for the capital
appropriation or whatever I remember you
saying I wonder if Ways and Means knew
about this remember when we talked about
it yeah is that so with that $ 18
million be captured in hb1 Melissa no
it's not an H so this would add it in so
this will give the general fund an extra
18 million well that's good news right
it is good news but I'm wondering
whether we ought to do it
earlier so that we don't take as much
from the rainy day
fund right because right
now uh we've got 160 million coming from
the rainy day fund so you could change
that to June 30
2020 five yes so that would hit fiscal
year 25 how about that
there's a good Mr chair all right so
June
yeah um okay so I'll I'll move that we
accept this provision with the amendment
to change July 1st 2025 to June 30
2025 okay all right you happy about that
yeah okay all those in favor yes okay
all right so amend all right
so and we'll get um we'll get Surplus
statements when when Mr Kane can do that
so does that does that mean that um the
revenue estimate for 26 goes up by$ 18
million we think so we hope so yes well
not for 26
for 25 25 so we have little oh okay I
see what yeah so I I don't know if you
got um there's a piece of paper I got
recently
um yes um Melissa can do you have copies
of
this this is
[Music]
um uh General and education trust funds
budget tracking
sheet um
so what this shows we don't just worry
about 26 and 27 we also worry about the
end of this year right and so because
the governor assumed revenues were
higher this year than house Ways and
Means did or will or something like that
her bottom line was taking 81 million
from the Gen from the rainy day fund
this page says 160 million
right or if you so so that's a big deal
right
cuz I think this 142 yeah so I think I
think I like doing that so okay so do we
vote Yes are we going to yeah I thought
okay we voted okay
okay so back
to anybody else want to say something no
oh okay go ahead yeah
yeah
um all right
so so this is keep with June 30th
okay
great all right so the next one um
section
186 do we know how that's different than
existing law because it seems to me what
this says is what we actually do but
maybe I'm wrong about
that 18
page for some reason 185 is not on my
list 185 is division three okay um 186
we have an email out to the governor's
office uh Mike Kan Mike Kane was
concerned about this one a little bit
and wanted some background admin
Services said ask the governor's office
so we are we are waiting for a response
from them yeah yeah I think it's
um it seems strange because I would have
thought that that's sort of what already
happens but anyway okay so wait for
my that's the r
yeah 187
yeah the sale so I don't like
187 because I don't like program
spending you know do this and then spend
it over over there I I'd rather you do
this and it affects the general fund and
over there you decide to spend and it
affects the general fund
so
um so I'm not inclined to accept
187 um Melissa and Jack what was the
weren't there funds from the sale of the
lonia state school designated for some
other purpose or or
what uh there's been a couple of bills
that have come through I think that's
what you're remembering but they didn't
end up passing there was one that was
giving money back to Laconia for some
infrastructure from the sale oh that's
what I'm remembering that's yeah and
that one did not end up passing the
house do we have any idea how much money
we're talking about here
I can look into it I knew it would going
back and forth yeah okay I was just
curious yes represent thank you the
other issue I have with that too is um
the last sent and such building shall be
used for state government office
space I think we would want to have that
a little more broad what if there's a
vendor that wants to come in and have a
cafeteria or some other thing you know
if that's not being used for state
government space it would be excluded I
think the probably the only so notice
this is 2023 law being changed right
this is last year's House Bill too so I
have a feeling the only thing being
changed is is the laps
sentence right the last sentence of this
oh we can just look at
okay oh so it may be already be in
law yeah that that that would be my
guess
but but if it's already in statute and
that's the only change wouldn't have
been
bolded or crossed out no because the way
it's written is repealed and reenacted
as follows right so you could have done
it that way right yeah it would be
interesting to have to read the original
statute I can make a note so
representative evil is looking at them
okay so it's it's changed quite
significantly oh is it okay
okay okay well we'll hang it's an
overall it's an overall rewrite okay
so maybe you'll print a difference or
something is it so so would that have
come through Das though or or that's
just the
governor I don't know who we can even
ask about it we could we'll ask Das
about it okay they were the ones that
gave us the information and before it
allocated 13 million um out or
acquisition land Building and
improvements to Granite one it it gave 2
million for necessary mechanical
upgrades so it's making it
vague because they don't know how yeah
yeah and the laps amount was in there
that laps language was in there so but
once again I I don't like connecting
this project be you know depends on that
project so okay um
all right 10 million oh here's a here's
another 10
million this is this is a RAID here yeah
well I we just hold off on that you want
to hold off on please I mean don't you
have other raids in
M here it shows the laps right here on
Canon
Mountain oh there you go did they did
put it in here so now we can bump it
here oh I see
interesting so that's that's interesting
where oh here yeah so she does have it
I'm just looking on the sheet for Canon
Mountain so all we're doing is sliding
that 18 over to the left a little that's
going to make but that's going to make
26 27 of course true anyway but yeah
whatever six of one half a dozen on the
other
right I just don't I have a feeling the
treasurer is not going to be happy with
the rainy day fund all of a sudden
getting $160 million
haon that's true we we were thinking it
wasn't really accounted
for it wasn't right because
um wherever house wayer means revenues
see what I mean yeah so it's not in
there so it's down here yeah so yes yes
the money part the bill the money is in
18 as in fiscal year 26 we moved it to
yes yes yeah okay we can we can I mean
we can reconsider at some later Point
want if we need to but but again you
know it's anyway it all flows to the
back to the bottom would you like us to
still prepare an amendment for that yes
you yes since we we I don't want to go
backwards all right um are we done with
this page all right so we're I guess we
we can we can break at this point um so
we're coming back at 1:15 to do
bills
and one is it 1:00 yes it's
1:00 okay we're coming back at 1:00 to
do bills I I also wanted to talk about
scheduling next
week so next week um I want to schedule
us for
Tuesday because um Wednesday is our
public hearing day right so we're going
to have house bill one and House Bill
two public hearing on
Wednesday um so I'd like
so that means we we don't have division
one and what happened to me on Wednesday
is that um education funding is meeting
the morning of Wednesday to finish our
bills so I won't be able to be here
Wednesday morning from 10 to two so
therefore what I'd like to do is have us
have our regular meeting uh 10 to 4 or
whatever on
Tuesday even though that's P that's town
meeting day is that a
problem okay I I'm guessing it's
probably a problem for representative
Sweeny who hasn't been here much but
because he's a selectman but other than
that so we would have our regular
meeting doing what we're doing now from
10: to 4: on
Tuesday um okay I I have a couple
meetings I have to move but that's okay
that okay yeah
any problems you guys your guys good
okay did you get
permission um yeah I'm I think I'm in
the process of getting permission right
so for Tuesday for Tuesday yes I I've
already let Janet know so it should be
in the she'll put it out for tonight for
the calendar okay
Monday Monday T so our our three days
next week will be Monday Tuesday Friday
but but uh Wednesday you have to be here
for a big public Hearing in the
afternoon in the afternoon 2: p.m. to
yeah and it can go late you know it
depends on how many people show up and
the other thing is that's town meeting
day so I mean some of us will have to
leave that but the way it is it's the
way it is
yeah
okay representative McGuire can I just
make one clarification just for the
record the audit fund set aside is
0.001% not
1% well that makes more I want to make I
want to make sure that's on it's about
two and a half million a year it's not
very thorough audits is that what you're
[Laughter]
saying okay um and then this Friday
right we're not meeting we we have
County right so three yeah the three of
us here of County so we are meeting
starting at 1:15 1:5 on this Friday yeah
right de so we have scheduled yes at
1:15 Dees to come in but we've also
invited dncr and fishing game and dncr
has already confirmed so we'll start out
with the permanent for all those earlier
and that that permitting stuff which is
a big section for us perfect and so this
afternoon I'm assuming there's going to
be spaces here and there between bills I
mean the bills aren't that big so
therefore we can go back to this house
actually the way we schedule that
there's no Gap so we can just go one to
the other to the other to the other so
there's no Gap this afternoon there's no
times
for one running right but I'm saying you
know representative Lynn's going to be
here for his two bills at 3 o' and
representative somebody else is going to
be here at some other time so I'm I'm
guessing there's going to be gaps right
and so therefore we can we can continue
with house building I don't think you're
going to have many
gaps there's too many bills
be why they're pretty they're mostly
very
minor I think what you're saying though
is you want to wait I mean there's no
requirement you wait for the prime
sponsor to work on the bill they don't
show up maybe at the
end well yeah
all right I I wasn't necessarily going
to take them in this order right
so that's my my thing
okay I'm stuck taking them in that order
yeah I think you I think you are that's
how you posted it they're all posted at
1:00 I can't do them all at 1:00 no but
you have to do them in the order that
you have them listed the only one that
technically is the one at one o00 the
rest of them you can change there's no
time on the rest of well I will say de
assuming that it's going to be second
mine and they will be here for that for
your bill for 619 so i' would like to
keep that at least second position
okay that's fine I also want to note
that um HB 619 is is a first committee
bill so that one um has a tighter
deadline than the rest of the bills okay
so that one and so that means we we have
to have a full committee something for
that one right so maybe can we do that
on Wednesday we were kind of hoping
maybe we might be able to sneak it in
depending on what the committee votes
for the status of it I don't know if
we're planning on retaining it doing an
amendment or whatnot yeah because we
could also vote on all of them do we
have any other first committee bills
this is the only Bill it's the other and
we're going to retain it right yeah yes
that would be my recomend but I would
just say all those other ones whatever
we recommend today we could vote on the
same day so we wouldn't just be voting
online oh you see what I'm saying so if
we do if you are intending to um retain
HB 619 that does push our date out to
April 3rd so they will all fall into the
same if you vote on doing OTP and itl
otpa that we need to have out by March
20th the full committee does so then
would need to speak it in on Wednesday
if we could yeah so right at the
beginning of the public hearing we could
have a real quick exact for this 619
yeah yeah to just but if well if you
chose to retain it you don't need to fit
that in on Wednesday okay oh we don't
have to no because all retained bills is
April
3D oh even if it's first committee but
we don't know that it's going to be
retained until the full committee
decides to right that's a fair statement
okay all right so um let's tell Janet to
schedule an exec session on
6:19 for Wednesday okay okay you want to
do like half hour 15 minutes 20 minutes
five minutes five minutes okay at at
1:5 right to okay
okay good all right we'll see you at one
o all right not 1:5 yes
not all right so I got to do more
this
e
e e
work session on House Bill 650
FN uh which is about removing references
to repeal funds and relative to State
Park and Robotics education
funds um
representative Maguire is the co main
sponsor of this bill and uh he had asked
me to convey to the committee that this
is basically a housekeeping
Bill representative cell yes this is
just sort of everybody has a packet of
the bills on their desk they also have a
packet of revised fiscal notes as well
so I just want to make sure everybody's
looking at the most upto-date
information for the revised fiscal notes
there's revised fiscal note packet on
your desk and the packet of
bills so this the fiscal note that you
should have um was revised on two
2525 so just want to make sure
everyone's looking at the right
information I'm sorry could you could
you repeat that sure the fisal note was
revised on February 25th 2025 so I just
want to make sure that's the one that
you're looking at okay and if it's not
in the bill that you have in front of
you it is in your revised fiscal note
packet so you'll have two two
packets
okay so basically the main things that
uh as I stated um there's just some
housekeeping that's uh uh fix ing this
this current RSA uh the main thing is uh
down on line
19 the for the uh unencumbered balances
of the robotics fun education
fund the uh there's a change to
currently they get
$750,000 a year the change is to cap it
at 1 million so that any money that uh
that goes above 1 million will lapse
into the general
general
fund does anybody want to comment on
it any discussion
so basically no discussion this will be
something that we're going to we're not
going to execute uh today but we will be
most likely making an OTP motion on this
one and when when we get everybody gets
back
okay yes representative eil um so this
went through sorry I think everybody's
just catching up here this went through
ways and means right and then it came
through on the house floor I just
wondered so remember um last term when
we had bills that had
been second committee bills coming to
finance we generally we asked what the
status was coming off the
floor if it was consent calendar or what
it
was sure okay um so it came out of
committee
came out of ways and means ought to pass
16 to zero um and then it went to the
house floor it was ought to pass um
majority accepted by a Voice vote on
February 20th and then referred to
finance all
right so just on these bills uh Mr Vice
chair then we're going to be deciding
whether to retain or just to make a
motion ought to pass and let them fly
off on their own is that the idea yes
okay but we should wait till the prime
is here is that yes I would like to do
that plus we're missing two two of our
people so
okay any further
discussion okay we close that work
session on House Bill
and me
we open up a session work session on
House Bill 619
FNA um would the sponsor like to speak
to this so I can just go down there that
would be great so I did
very much um so unlike the other my name
is Karen Eble uh marac district 7 unlike
the other bills that we're dealing with
this Finance is a first committee bill
in this case it didn't so it came
directly to us um it didn't go through a
a committee previously so you may recall
um at the hearing um what the upshot of
this bill is um in the last budget we
put a couple of million dollars into the
solid waste management fund which is a
fund that is a um is a grant program for
municipalities and for businesses um to
use for Waste diversion efforts and also
there's an emphasis in here that we
actually we did this as part of hb2 last
time have a 50% priority for food waste
diversion and you may remember from the
hearing we talked a lot about the
benefit
of food waste aversion and how we can um
how we it can help save money in the
long run and it also helps with landfill
capacity um the bill does call for a
million dollars in general funds but you
may also recall that at the last um at
the original hearing the conversation on
the bill talked rather quickly because
of the revenue situation ation we're in
into um alternative sources of income
for something like this so the main
point of my presentation to you today
and to the and the materials that I
brought you um is to talk a little bit
about what um like 30 to 35 states in
the United States do um in the uh with
respect to funding when it comes to um a
management fund like this and that is
that what they what a lot of states do
is they have the The Tipping fee is the
fee that you pay per ton when your trash
goes to the landfill right or waste to
energy plant and so in many many cases
what most people do is they have a rate
that they contract for you know like
municipalities like in my case in New
London it's $66 a ton um so
what a huge number of states do is on
top of the Tipping fee there's also what
they call a waste disposal search charge
and when we were talking about that in
the hearing uh representative Maguire
asked for more information on that
option um as a way of replacing general
fund Revenue so what I did in the packet
I I did reprint my testimony which you
guys would have had from before the
second thing in the packet um is an
email that was sent to us by Mike gorc
um responding to rep representative
Maguire's inquiry because um he was
asking what the fund what the fees were
in other states in the in the area so um
in Connecticut you can see it's a
$150 main um the second the page after
Mike's email I printed out the statute
Maine has a variety of SE charges
depending on the thing that's going into
the
landfill um Massachusetts doesn't have a
sear charge but it works through
renewable energy credits I wouldn't say
that was a model that we were going to
use New Jersey is $3 a ton uh
Pennsylvania
625 Vermont is
$6 um the other document that I Prov
provided to you later on in the packet I
actually went to ncsl and I asked them
to do a 50 state survey of uh waste
disposal SE charges and I just got this
like two days ago so you can see all the
states that do
this
um so that is that I just for context as
we're looking at the as as we're looking
at this um fee discussion I just want to
describe what the regional situation is
with landfills so I think just as a
starting point we all know that the
interstate commerce clause doesn't allow
us to ban outof State waste coming into
our state so if you have a private
landfill um you're allowed by the law
under certain State restrictions to have
out of state waste so that's and that's
sort of the situation in New Hampshire
that's why about half of the waste that
comes into New Hampshire goes into these
large landfills and it is outof State
waste when you're looking at Maine for
instance if we're thinking about uh the
fees that they charge you have to
remember that Maine is a state owned
landfill they own their own landfill so
um this whole issue of the interstate
commerce clause or whatever just really
doesn't even come up nobody is going to
be raising the issue because
if you own if a state or a municipality
owns the landfill they just take what
they want right so any fees that they're
charging they're kind of charging
themselves in a way so so that's one
thing about Maine in Vermont they only
have one f one landfill it's a private
landfill it's run by cassella it's way
up in the Northeast Kingdom um so the
whole idea of trucking from out of state
to Vermont isn't as much of an is kind
of an issue and the other thing is
Vermont has very tight regulations on
what is allowed to go into a landfill so
you have Maine which has a state-owned
landfill and isn't really taking out of
state waste you have Vermont which has
one landfill severe restrictions way up
North you have Massachusetts I think at
this point they only have one operating
landfill and maybe a couple of waste to
energy plants and the very large
percentage of their waste is e either
being trucked out to Ohio or
Pennsylvania or it's coming to New
Hampshire so um and in Connecticut
they've lost a vast amount of their
disposal capacity because their waste to
energy plants are decreasing so I just I
just say that to give sort of the
regional context of what we're looking
at here and why I won't say there's a
bullseye but there's really a big option
for out of state waste in the state of
New Hampshire
so then when you're talking about waste
disposal sech charges you have to charge
the same um search charge under the
interstate commerce clause on everything
that's coming into the state so out of
state and instate
waste but when we so the proposal would
be that you take the waste disposal
search charge money and you put it all
into the solid waste management fund
that we
created but the concept here is that in
addition to using the solid waste
management fund just as a grant program
you use the fee money to basically fund
the solid waste Bureau at the depart at
at Dees so you're using the dispo this
the searge money instead of General
funds to fund your Solid Waste work and
a lot of what they do is oversee
disposal and we're talking about
disposal right so in looking through the
ncsl materials and looking what
regionally what they do with it a lot of
this is is what a lot of states do they
fund within their agency their Solid
Waste work with these disposal search
charges and they also use them to fund
grants and so um I think you know since
we're doing a lot of exploration of fees
and and how long ago they were set and
all that and and trying to find ways to
replace the general fund money that has
been lost this is an option that is not
unusual at all in fact it's common I
don't really understand why we haven't
been doing it um it would replace
general fund money it would help out I
think the solid waste Bureau within the
waste division at Dees because it would
be more of a sustainable um line of
funding and it also supports the long
range Solid Waste Management plan
because there's something in there about
trying to find more sustainable funding
or alternatives to general fund so
that's that's the idea um there's a lot
of ways to work this out
um I don't know if director whims is
here but I did I okay I did uh talk to
him about putting together some some
language that was based on a bill that
we did before the numbers that we were
talking about what I said to him why
don't we start the discussion at 350 we
can go up we can go down uh we can
estimate the funds that would come out
of that amount of money the thing to
know about it is
that we can once the money is in the
solid waste management fund if we want
to and this is what how we had conceived
of it you can actually refund the money
that municipalities paid back to the
municipalities
and you can keep the money that you got
from out of state within the fund for us
to use for our agency purposes that
doesn't violate the interstate commerce
clause so we have once we would get the
money and put it in the solid waste
management fund we have flexibility on
how it could be used
so I actually you know it it's obviously
up to the committee and I think we'll
have to talk about it further but I
think it's a really good option for us
to consider as a way of um replacing
general fund dollars with this sort of
money um to help out the um with the
whole budget
situation okay so we presumably going to
be retaining this bill however in light
of what You' stated we will wait to see
if there's an amendment uh would would
there be one forthcoming yeah there were
well I think this was what I thank you
um Mr Vice chair I would urge the
committee I mean I think we could even
vote today to retain the to retain the
bill and it's a first committee bill so
maybe we should um I do have some
language I didn't make multiple copies
that I could share with you guys but I
didn't prepare an amendment that's like
the amendment because I think we have
some more discussion we should have
about how we want the money used and
what we want the fee to be and that sort
of thing representative Ms if we do
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question do you do you have any idea
or any sense of what the total
tonnage coming into landfalls is think
it would be really great if if uh
director whimet could come up here and
talk a little bit more about the money
and I I want to make sure that I've
accurately describe things
sure yes uh good afternoon members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike wisat I serve as director of the
waste management division for New
Hampshire Dees and representative M
asked your question um over the last
several years the um total amount of
waste disposed of whether from instate
both instate and out ofate waste has
hovered around 2 million ton and um last
year we had a little bit of a drop off
in that it was around 1.75 or 1.78
million tons so if you you know look in
round numbers if you look at the 2
million ton figure a a $3.50 fee would
be expected to collect about $7
million and if you want to break it down
based on the description that
representative eel has presented um the
the right now the hp1 uh you know
proposed budgets for the solid waste
program in full all positions fully
loaded you know all all overhead the
solid waste landfill grant program that
we make payments to municipalities on um
that is um hovering just under just
about $3 million per year so if you were
to raise $7 million in in funds you
would be able to take that entire
program off of General funds you would
also be we would expect and this these
are numbers I just recently gotten from
my staff it's a little bit hard for us
to estimate how much money would go back
to
municipalities because we don't really
have hard numbers on that but based on
work we've done if we look really
conservatively at it it might be out of
that $7 million figure it might be
somewhere on the order of between 1 and
2 million so let's say it's the worst
not the worst case it's a good case if
it's 2 million going back to
municipalities I think it's less than
that but if it were that'd be about 5
million and that would leave 2 million
um for U making grants to uh
municipalities to nonprofits to
businesses to anybody who's going to
advance a technology and a facility
that's going to help divert waste and
and invent increase our recycling rates
so so it's a it's you know
comprehensively it really addresses a
lot of the needs that the program and
and our and our state's management of
solid waste has been lacking in over the
years yes follow up just follow up so so
just to make sure I'm clear so what
you're saying is if we did this all the
expenses of your division would be fully
funded by this fee that's correct we
believe it would do that it would it
would completely fund that budget and it
would take 19 positions off of General
funds
yes representative Rong thank you Mr
chair so um have you seen in the
experience of other states that have
this type of search charge that there is
more waste diversion maybe to re
recycling or or like reduction with food
waste so over time you would kind of see
the amount of money raised would be
lowering because there's less waste
being in because municipalities are out
of state or businesses want to reduce
that the amount that they're paying for
Waste Disposal yes so that would
actually even though it would result in
less revenues would you also say it it
would help us reduce the whole issue
with you know a chunk of issue with
solid waste sure the the way that the
fund is designed is to you know kind of
work work that fee downward if you will
because the all of the monies that are
used are in many respects either
directly or indirectly focused on
reducing the amount of waste that we
dispose of and increasing the amount of
waste that is managed through more
sustainable methods like composting or
recycling or waste reduction that's a
followup Mr chair yes thank you and
representative eel as far as the
amendment goes that would delineate the
uh sir charge and I would assume there'
probably be some administrative Ru
making that would be required by Dees
that would be incorporated in the
amendment right I mean so I just it's
not quite at a point I we need to pass
it all out but basically what it says is
the it it authorizes the fund um to be
used in a way to help the department as
we talked about to replace general fund
dollars um it talks about the grant uh
program it talks about the refund to the
municipalities the mechanism for that um
and it establishes the search charge by
statute I mean we could allow increases
at the you know if the if the if the
agency wanted to do it I mean that's
within our power it and it also just
sort of sets up how the how the um money
is paid how it's
refunded um and and that's basically the
upshot it's a pretty comprehensive um
look at the thing I think I think you're
right if it works over time the amount
of money that would be raised through
the sear charge would start to decrease
but that would also mean that we're
accomplishing our goals right and it
also maybe there'll be less out of state
waste here I mean it's just kind of I
mean I I like it because I think it's
just a really Common Sense alternative
to what we're doing right now it's a
commonly used alternative that other
states use um and you know let's face it
especially when it comes to out of state
waste New Hampshire continues to Bear
the burden of the landfills that are
here and yes they're bonded if they're
leaking or something like that but
they're with us for perpetuity so it
seems to me that it's fair to have outof
state waste be paying this you know
people like Somerville or whatever if
they're sending their trash here that
they give a little bit of a sech charge
to us I mean otherwise all they're doing
is paying the Tipping fee yeah um I mean
I think it's a very New Hampshire
approach to the situation one more
followup followup and I just want to
make note and see if you agree with me
that this would also help address leech
a treatment so the lower our Solid Waste
costs go the lower our costs for
lee8 and there's there's a you know a
domino effect because then you're saving
on transport ation costs of the hauling
so okay well thank you very much yeah I
mean we talked a little bit about this I
mean for municipalities as they divert
their waste as they decrease what's
going into the landfills it's not just
the Tipping fee money in some ways
that's the smaller part of it it's the
trucking so for New London we pay almost
$700 a hopper load to go to the dump to
to the landfill and that adds up really
really really quickly and I think I told
you guys because we have a food waste
program that only some of our family
like 170 families participate in and the
last year we diverted 36 tons or 32 tons
of food waste and our Public Works guy
said that that ended up at least once or
twice a month we had like one or two
fewer um Hoppers that had to get trucked
up to mount harur that right there is
$1,400 um anyway um I I hope I look
forward to talking uh to the committee
about it um it's certainly something
that we've been talking about at the
solid waste working group for really
long time um it does support our goals
here in the state of New Hampshire and
it has the benefit at a benefit of
replacing general fund dollars which are
hard to come by representative MS thank
you thanks for taking my question is
there is there anything in current
statute that limits how these uh how
funds from this um or monies from this
fund can be utilized and and and to be
more specific I mean what I'm I'm
specifically interested in is there any
limitation on funds being used
to um you know maybe address problems
associated with landfills that have that
have been closed for a while no so very
specifically the way the fund is
currently structured it's a grant
program for municipality for New
Hampshire municipalities and businesses
there's no authorization for this money
to be used by the department or in any
other way because it's a dedicated fund
that's the thing with dedicated funds
right you limit how they can be used but
in this case the fund last time we we
funded it with general fund dollars so
that's what started my bill I wanted to
put more general fund dollars into the
management fund but the way the
conversation went in finance a couple of
weeks ago we started talking about
alternative ways of funding and this
helps fund the grant program but it has
the extra huge benefit of helping to
fund um agency work the solid waste the
the solid waste Bureau which all the
solid waste which much of the solid
waste work takes place in um and again I
I got all this research from NS ncsl
because I wanted to show you guys that
this isn't unusual in fact we're the
outliers that because we don't do
this um and Vermont mat and a lot of
them they they really have made great
strides in their waste diversion through
their Grant programs and I was like like
bulbs going off when I realized it was
all coming out of this sear charge money
that they were getting so have I missed
anything don't think so okay any other
questions okay thank
you so representative
Campbell sorry oh yes can I just pause
you for one second um
yeah representative uh chair Maguire
asked um deputy secretary state
Hennessey to come in to speak to HB 164
and hb67 and she has limited time so I
didn't know if there was any way if we
could um hear her now even though it's
out of order because he invited her in
this morning absolutely we can do that
uh so let me close out the work session
on House Bill 619
FNA
and what uh what are the Bills again the
uh hb6 4 and
hb67 it's um okay record retention in
voter accessibility so I'll open up a
work session on House Bill 164
FN which is relative to local record
retention and I'll
invite yes representative
Sweeney thank you Mr Vice chair I was
just uh the sponsor asked me to just I
guess we're not introducing it so yes so
I'll allow you to uh to introduce or to
talk on behalf of the sponsor sure
yes uh thank you all uh representative
Joe Sweeney from Rockingham 25 I'm just
uh introducing House Bill 164 on behalf
of the sponsor
I uh he has an amendment that I was just
handed uh that I had not seen um I had
talked to him about the likelihood of us
retaining this bill and trying to figure
out if we can work it out in the budget
uh but I know the uh deputy secretary
state is here to speak to it as well and
I would just defer to her but thank
you yes
welcome good afternoon everyone my name
is Hennessy I am the deputy secretary of
state and I am here to speak on HB 164
which relates to my office um within the
Secretary of State's office we have the
division of archives and Records
management and what this bill would do
would be to fund a position that we
already have created the um local
records manager position and what that
position would be responsible for is
helping um municipalities
um with how to properly post uh right to
knowable documents on their website um
in addition this person would be able to
help with um clerks or other people that
are using their Town websites be able to
um put them in accessible format um next
year is a big deadline for ensuring that
all websites have accessible information
or any information on websites is an
accessible format so
um that is what this position would do
I'm happy to take any questions it did
um overwhelmingly pass the um Judiciary
Committee um I believe it passed last
year in judiciary as well so there was a
lot of support
there thank you any
questions and I can talk to the
amendment too that would be great thank
you it it shifts the cost to um the year
um that they would take place the the
fiscal year so um it just aligns when
the position would be
funded um to when the enactment of the
law takes
place representative evil Mr chair I
don't I don't know how you want to do do
this procedurally but I'd be willing to
make a motion to retain this bill for
future discussion or were you thinking
you would wait on those motions um we're
going to wait on the motions and when
representative Maguire gets back and
representative wer we may execute some
bills at the end at the end those that
we want to retain will probably execute
but I'm not going to do that until the
other two so they're coming today okay
yes they are thank you thank you
any questions on the
amendment okay I think we're good and
we'll uh we'll close out this work
session on House Bill 164
FN Alissa which is the next one uh hp67
uh 67
67 okay i' like to open up a work
session on House Bill 67 FN relative to
agreements with the Secretary of State
for the use of accessible voting
systems I can talked to
the do I have to go down there yes
representative will please um go I'll
crawl out of my hole
here thank you Mr chair for the record
my name is Karen eel and I represent uh
marac district 7 so um what you have
before you is a bill that provides for
um direct cities and towns to enable
access to voting for individuals with
disabilities during elections it has to
do with accessible voting machines um I
have discussed this with the prime
sponsor I've also discussed it with
deput secretary deputy secretary of
state um Hennessy um they are very
supportive of this bill it does have a
$100,000
appropriation um I don't want to speak
for her but my understanding is that the
appropriation could be removed and they
would still be able to do the job that
they need to do with respect to the uh
voting machines and the only other thing
and I don't have an amendment um with me
but I know the prime sponsor in
communication with um Miss Hennessy
wanted to move the effective date of the
uh of the bill out to December
31st right
2025 um and I think if there are
additional questions she'd be the best
person to talk to about
it okay thank
you assistant secretary would you like
to
speak thank you everyone thank you Mr
chair members of the committee again my
name is Aaron Hennessy and before us is
hb67 and it deals with accessible voting
in local elections last year the
legislature passed a bill I believe it
was
1264 that um required the use of
accessible voting systems in local
elections we've used them in state and
federal elections for years now um we
our version is called the oneforall
device you may have seen it in a white
tent in your polling location um and
this allows anyone um anyone to use it
but also anyone with a disability who
may um be um seeing impaired or have a
shake in their hand or um be um have um
limbs that are missing that do not allow
them to use um a pen or pencil to fill
in their ballot when they're voting um
we fully support the premise of the
legislation uh the way the appropriation
is worded um we would never see that
$100,000 so I'm going to tell you we
don't need it our Hava fund um requires
us to have 12 years of um operating
expenses in the balance to ensure that
um the mandates of the help America vote
act are fully funded for the State of
New Hampshire going forward without the
Reliance on any additional Federal
funding Appropriations and we support
that as well um within that fund we have
enough money to purchase the new um
accessible voting equipment which we
will share with cities and towns for
their local elections they will be
responsible for paying the programming
cost for local elections um and we would
be responsible for paying the
programming cost for state and federal
elections so again we do not need the
$100,000 appropriation we would be
paying um for the this equipment with
Hava
funds I'm sorry could you say which fund
again um it's technically it's the
election fund um but people refer to as
Hobbit
funds any questions for the
secretary yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you um for taking my question
what's the balance in the El the
election fund presently I don't know off
the top of my head I think um
unencumbered funds is probably about 12
or 13 million oh okay thank and it cost
about a million plus dollars to run the
Hava office a
year okay thank you so that that's a
non-aps fund then it just y okay thank
you and it's has audits by the federal
government okay thank you representative
Ms thank you and thanks for coming in um
I think you said that the U the cost of
program the machines for federal and
state elections would be paid for out of
this state fund correct
um I believe they're either I believe
they're paid for by Hava funds I have to
check on the state would be respons the
state has always paid for the
programming of the um of the accessible
voting equipment in state and federal
elections and then the locals uh uh
folks are responsible for for that at
the for Town elections correct the
what's the approximate cost of that
thanks for the question um so the
legislation last year set up a pilot
program so right now we're loaning our
equipment to the locals they are using
our current vendor um with our equipment
that's about 10 years old now and they
are paying approximately $600 per ballot
um so it's not per ballot page it's
about so if you have a town ballot that
has three pages it would be $600 if you
have a school ballot that has another
three pages that's another $600 if you
have another school ballot that has
another three pages that's another $600
so some of the towns are seeing um a
little bit High expenses to program
local elections so we are when we um
we're working on our RFP now for the new
equipment and our hope is is that the
responses we get would have lower costs
to program the elections because we do
recognize that it's could be excessive
for a lot of locations followup um given
that cost which is not
inconsequential um why not expand the um
rules around absentee ballots so that
anyone with a disability can vote
absentee you you would have to ask
yourself that question as a legislator
um I don't have the authority to do that
it's in our constitution who is allowed
to vote um via
absentee any further questions
representative eil thank you um I I just
did wanted to note for you that the
prime sponsor is here now representative
page so um was there another amendment
to this that you were interested in
seeing in addition to the date
change uh thank you uh representative
Evel so to take away the appropriation
we do not need the money um the general
funds and also um the date change is
what we are looking for um we do not
want to have to enter into new
agreements with towns for equipment that
we don't have yet so if we can and push
the agreement out to when we um
12312 would be an appropriate date we
should have the new equipment by
then Mr so so I'd be happy to work with
um the Secretary of State's office and
the prime to bring in an amendment for
this bill reflecting the removal of the
$100,000 okay and the day change any
other
questions thank you madam secretary for
your testimony uh since the prime
sponsor is here would they like to say a
few words or it's
optional yes yes Mark paage I represent
exitor I'm the prime sponsor of the bill
um literally the OS is drawing up the
amendment that I've worked out with the
secretary of state and eel
representative eel to to do that so it
does just extends the pilot program to
the end of 2025 makes the effective date
of the full program December 31st 2025
essentially just you know and and the
secretary and removes the $100,000 which
would be happy happy news to you um so
that's in the works literally on the
printer as we speak so happy to take
questions but I
but Rong thank you Mr chairman so
representative Paige so you the
amendment should be ready today you
think yes oh okay thank you it's
y representative
if it's ready before we've wrapped up
here feel free to bring it over here and
you know we could discuss it and even
possibly ex uh make our recommendation
to sure yeah we'll do it's but if it's
not done gotcha okay thank you all right
thank you thank you very
much
any that's it I think that's so um with
that I'll close out the work session on
House Bill 67 FN okay and I will turn
over the gavel to the chair so so what
do we do okay so you're everything's
done great let's go home we're we're on
511 so you can pick it up here so Mr
chair 511 we introduce 511 is next
that's next okay we skipped around a
little but I cired the ones that we uh
you Circle the ones we did no we did
yeah okay we do we take any votes or no
we waiting for you waiting for me for
speaker okayer all right 511 this is
what you have left it's 511 282
216 okay 66 now I kind of wanted on 511
did we do 66 no no okay CU
um uh representative Lynn wanted to be
here for 511
and66 should I call him
maybe um but he was coming at 3 yeah
sounds like we're not ready ahead for
one and give him a little chance to get
here yeah how about um since Carol's
here should we
do uh 216
and yeah I would have let you go Joe I
would have let you
go is that
right yeah so Carol's here for for 216
representative Maguire
right yeah let's do 216
okay uh I'm representing Carol Maguire
mayac District
27 and House Bill
216 despite its very ominous fiscal note
actually passed the house on consent
because the Edna committee said we don't
believe the fiscal
note uh since then I have
investigated and had um legislative
research look into
what how many individuals actually are
out on workers comp for more than a year
because what this bill does is
it repeals the current and practically
since forever limit of one year of time
on workers
compensation that applies towards your
pension
service
um because
let's see it's it started a couple of La
last year when we had a bill about two
individuals who were grievously injured
on the job two policemen who were shot
in the line of duty and
survived but
had uh you know like a dozen operations
before they had to retire on disability
and one of them was concerned because he
had something like nine nine years and
some months of
seniority
but and then he had you know enough time
out on dis ability in addition to that
to add up to 10 years but it didn't
count for him and so the Edna committee
said that appears to be an arbitrary
limit because our feeling was that
hardly anybody is going to be spend a
year out on workers compensation
but it turns out that's the kind of data
that nobody actually records the data
that I was able to get was from one
insurance company that reported to the
uh insurance department that more than
10% of some group of people were
receiving benefits a year after the
incident that caused them to be out on
workers comp and I don't know if that's
because they were out on their second or
third operation or whatever but it
struck me as an extraordinarily High
number um that's the number that the
retirement system used because they
don't keep track of it either uh the
only thing I'm sure of is that we pass
this bill the re the 100,000 or so for
reprogramming will come into effect
that's for sure uh how many people this
would affect I don't know my personal
feeling is that it's a very tiny number
but I have no data to back that up so
I'm concerned that this might be a pig
and a poke and while we like the concept
of saying that somebody who is
recovering from an on the job
injury should not be penalized for
their um for having suffered this
injury I also don't want to say that if
there's a lot of them the rest of the
taxpayers in the state who will be
paying into the retirement fund to cover
them because they're not contributing
while they're on workers comp um I don't
know how how much this would tax all of
us in order to support it and so I'm I
like the concept but I can't really
right now recommend that you you pass it
immediately because we don't really know
what it's going to cost thank you
questions from the committee no have did
you consider instead of just crossing
out not an excess of year make it not an
excess of 18 months two years we have no
data if I had information that the
people who are out for a year are all
back to work in a year and a half I do
it but right now I have no information
right but we could sort of if we did it
incrementally then we could see what the
change was right and you would pay the
$100,000 reprogramming cost every time
wow all right Melissa if if if we were
to accept this bill into house bill two
do you know how because some of these
numbers are kind of scary right is that
going to yeah so because this
expenditures and I do want to know in
the fiscal note it does say scalable so
this was just retirement giving us a uh
a parameter if 10% had retired within
the six months it's definitely could go
way down could go way up probably not
way up but it could go way down
depending on the people to your question
representative McGuire this is just an
expenditure there's no appropriation for
this um so there it will not right
impact the budget at all the the
information well as I said when we
considered it need DNA we looked at it
and said this number is
ridiculous all all of our intuition said
it should be very much
smaller but there would not be any
appropriate ations would all be folded
down to the um employers of people in
the retirement system but but we pay for
benefits so if if the benefits of every
employee went up this you know 0.1% or
whatever the number is that's that's a
big number the impact would happen in
fiscal year 28 so it's outside the
budget yes the um the retirement system
calculates theirs every two years and
that and this would be folded into the
rate that every town school district and
the state pays I see so effectively
would affect the the unfunded
ECT the what affect the
um um contribution rate the UAA yes yes
it would affect the UA that
end and if it if we knew what it was no
matter how large we could argue about
whether that was appropriate but I'm I'm
very concerned that it's a total unknown
we don't know how many people would be
affected we don't know for how long and
I have been unable to find any better
data so I'm sorry about that I
understand all right representative
Ms than thank you um for taking my
question um what if we limited this to
just group two in place no it would
equally well apply to some at do who was
mangled in an in an industrial accident
or Run Over By by a truck or whatever
okay it would it in our opinion it would
only apply to people who were grievously
injured on the job and we certainly hope
that's a very tiny number but I can't
prove
it represent evil so um thank you for
being here so if I understand what
you're saying are you recommending that
we itl the bill or retain it which is
your recommendation uh retain in case we
find find out what it's worth because
it's certainly not going to cause any
cost anything this
year Lord willing and there's nobody
that gets so injured but um
um but if we find out how big it is then
we can have a more sensible
discussion all right representative R
thank you Mr chair so would this apply
retroactively do we have any situation
let's say there was no once a person
retires for any reason their pension is
set okay it would apply to someone who
is who was injured previously and is
still out on disability or coming back
from
disability um if somebody who was
injured five years ago and spent a year
and a half on disability retired after
this goes into effect it would apply to
them it would okay thank you it it the
the effective date is essentially the
date you actually retire okay thank you
so thank you representative does anyone
else here have information on this bill
that they would like to share with
us no all right see oh yes I see a hand
okay thank you for coming
back oh good thank you
nice to see you all again so soon so so
are you like the new Marty or we don't
have such a person the new Marty starts
on Monday oh
terrific so um Diana and I have been
filling in okay uh and we'll probably
continue to have a role through the end
of this session as things transition
over to the new guy okay um for the
record I'm Mark Kavanaugh Deputy counsel
and compliance office of the New
Hampshire retirement system and uh as we
testified in Edna and
as chairman McGuire indicated just now
there are no statistics we had reached
out to labor and specifically the
workers comp section they said we don't
collect the data that way um I confirmed
that with the
commissioner of of the Department of
Labor who is on our
board I think if the data was available
they would have given it to us and he
made a good point which is whatever data
they have they don't distinguish between
government and non-government workers
it's everyone is covered by workers con
so their data is not going to be just
government workers so you can't if they
have data I'm not even sure how
representative it was because of the
unique nature of public employment
Workforce as opposed to the the vast
private in uh record um with respect to
our cost estimate it was as Melissa
described let's just pick a number
that's easily scalable you can you can
take 10% and you move the decimal either
way as many places as you want to get to
where you feel is is is accurate for the
number um but that was just a starting
point it no no predictive value and no
opinion about what the the true size or
number of people would extend beyond a
year I would say that um for people who
are just shy of 10 years well if their
workers's comp leads to a permanent
disability that doesn't matter because
there's no years of service requirement
to get an accidental disability
retirement from us so uh it might have
helped someone who's had a long Illness
but is not going to qualify them for
accidental disability retirement because
it's not permanent that extra service
credit might get them to the 10-year
vesting that they could stop working and
then collect a vested deferred benefit
later on when when they reach the age
that's necessary uh but a lot of I think
a lot of our cases do go to ADR and
that's why they don't extend beyond a
year as much as that you might see
elsewhere where there isn't a disability
permanent disability benefit uh
available to say in Private
Industry current law says there's this
cut off after a year correct so don't
you have data because you got to know
when to cut somebody off oh no what they
do
is we receive the information but I
wouldn't call it data in in respect
that as part of the application process
they must provide a memo of payment
stating when their workers comp began
and when it ended and if it's more than
a year we say okay here's your 12 years
of 12 months of service but we don't
write down somewhere else how many other
months they were on because it's not
related to us doing anything with it so
I suppose you go to every one of these
people go in their file find that memo
and compile that data I uh but it's not
something that was regularly captured or
or does that come from Das uh it comes
from the workers comp
carrier oh it's a standard thing and you
you might have a series of them as they
keep extending your benefit so initially
you'll come in and say okay you're in
date of injury you benefits start 3 days
later you're approved for four weeks
here's the amount you get after four
weeks they extend it they give you
another memo we just look at the all we
need is one memo of a weekly
indemnification benefit as opposed to a
lump sum settlement
to
qualify or meet the requirement that the
injury be work related so we rely on and
and defer to the Judgment of labor on
whether something's work related if we
see that memo of compensation if a
member doesn't has been denied a claim
by the carrier or the
employer appeals
it enters into a lump some settlement
without ever having received a weekly
benefit the burden of proof that it was
work rated shifts to the individual
member and we don't get and we don't the
lump sum is not proof of work
relatedness because a work work com
Carri is going to settle something for
100 bucks just to get away from it and
not have to litigate it uh and we had
quite a few years ago certain attorneys
that took advantage of that and and knew
that if they could just get a a lump sum
that carriers were more than happy to
give and get out from under a long
prolonged appeal process and then coming
to us and claiming hey we've got proof
of compensation therefore it's work
rated uh so we went and got the statute
changed at that point uh so doesn't the
state only use one particular workman's
comp carrier or no I I believe they do
but I don't want to speak to that I
don't work at Das okay but they may be
even
self-insured yeah oh and this is for
everybody right right so municipalities
have primx and uh and the like primex is
the biggest one that I'm familiar with I
think the state might
self-insure okay yeah all right so we
might be able to get data just for state
employees uh um it might be Poss well no
this is workers comp so I mean self
self-insured would be you're carrying
the economic risk but the claims are
still being processed through Labor I
see there's a unified process for all
employers to to apply and have appeals
and the like sure okay all right so is a
thing sure
okay um I'd like to make a motion to
HB
FM second that motion okay any
discussion no okay all in
favor yeah looks unanimous
there assuming Mr clerk voted
for what's that oh
okay are we done with that
okay all right representative Sween I
think representative
111 yes yes yes
yes oh 511 was already circled no
no
okay all right thank you very
much okay my pen is
running I understand it was
premature okay my pen is running out of
being oh Horrors okay so now we have let
me get the bill here House Bill 511
cooperation with Federal immigrant
authorities and we represent recognize
representative Sweeny uh thank you Mr
chair and members of division one for
the record representative Joe Sweeney
from Rockingham 25 uh this is House Bill
511 that I'm introducing uh relative to
cooperation with Federal immigration
authorities this came out of the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee unanimously um I believe the
floor vote only had six detractors in
the house with the rest of us voting for
it uh they worked out the policy side of
it on our front for here today uh on the
finance side there's a I guess I'd say a
speculative fiscal note where if there
was a a high threshold number of
enforcement actions it would lead to the
potential need for an additional staffer
in the Department of
Justice I don't I don't foresee a high
level of enforcement actions taken from
this and I also know uh since we passed
the bill originally the state police are
entering into the
287g uh which opens up to Federal
funding for for those sorts of programs
uh so I not to say that I don't think
it's a it's a real fiscal note but I
think there's there's not a lot of meat
on the bone for spending in this so I
think we would be comfortable moving
ought to pass uh as is I I don't think
this actually has to be in the budget
conversation okay I'll take any
questions if there are any so Melissa
this wouldn't affect the budget we think
or we don't know um I with repres what
representative Sweeney said um one there
is no authorization of positions in this
bill nor are there is there an
appropriation for positions if um the
Department of Justice did need the
position they speak of but two they do
qualify that statement with that only if
the cases get to a certain level would
they need that position so as of the way
the bill is right now um this would not
impact the budget
okay any questions for representative
swen
don't see any all right and anybody else
here wanted to join in the conversation
I see one okay thank you thank you
represent thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Kate Horan
representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties I do want to
point out this will have a fiscal impact
on the counties County jails um couple
of things right now counties are only
allowed to hold for two reasons one if
someone is facing State charges or two
if there is a contract right now only
two Counties have contracts to hold ice
detainees that's marac marac has a rider
on their Marshall contract to hold and
straford has the ice Detention Facility
they contract directly with ice the rest
of the counties do not have the
authority to hold and this likely if we
were to hold someone after the
resolution of their state charges would
lead to litigation in addition if we are
holding these folks it's about $140 a
day to hold somebody we also have to pay
their medical expenses which you all
know can get very expensive you're all
members of your
delegation and there's no time limit in
here on how long we're holding them
right now the process for an ice detain
I'm going to use Hillsboro as an examp
example cuz they don't have a contract
someone comes
in um they are detained they see a bail
commissioner and they're released as
soon as we know that person is going to
be released Hillsboro County calls ice
and says hey this person has a detainer
are you going to come and get them I
will point out ice in Manchester is 2
minutes away from the County
Correctional
Facility a lot of the times they will
say no we're not coming to get them we
don't want to come and get them so then
this bill puts us in a position of so
are we holding them are we not holding
them which and then also if we are
holding them but RSA 30b has not changed
are we then facing litigation so this
will cost the County's money it may not
affect the state or the state budget but
this will cost County's
money um so what does an RSA 30b it is
the two reasons why we are allowed to
hold an individual
oh I see at a County Correctional
Facility this would it be a third thing
this would be a third thing that is not
addressed in this bill that issue is not
addressed I see and if we were to change
RSA 30b presumably you'd want uh some
money for this purpose correct all right
representative
wer yeah Rockingham County has had
federal prisoners before we've made
money out of it and my recollection is
that the feds would also pay for their
meals and their any medical work why Is
this different um a detain a detainer is
different than a warrant we are only
allowed to so um the reason we can hold
someone who let's say has a warrant out
in Cal California is because of
agreements with the governors across the
states to hold someone that agreement
does not exist in Rockingham County now
right now your superintendent is working
on a contract but that may or may not
happen with in the next 6 to eight
months we don't know it's not something
that we can ask for well we can ask for
it but it's not up to the county as to
whether or not they get that contract
right that's that's a decision for the
feds I guess the difference is that
those were people who were arrested
correct feds these people have not yet
been arrested correct thank you
representative Ms thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming in and um you know
explaining this um was this brought up
during the hearing in criminal justice
um unfortunately the way the association
works we need to vote as a full
executive committee before we can take
positions on the bills and this bill was
scheduled before we were able to meet as
an executive committee but I did speak
to representative Sweeney in the hallway
afterwards and we did send a letter to
the criminal justice committee before
they exec the bill and we sent out an a
letter to the entire house pointing out
these issues
representative evil well could we have
that letter again as a reminder I'm
happy to uh I've also spoken to
representative Roy because the Senate
has a companion bill and the correction
superintendents have come up with
language that they think works I'm happy
to provide that to the committee as well
um that you could add an amendment on to
here thank you so is the is the Senate
Bill otherwise the same or no there is
one slight
difference in the language but the
concept is the same gotcha okay all
right rep representative Sweeny I guess
thank you Mr chairman uh when can we get
the amendment language I can send it to
you as soon as I get back to my computer
thank you representative cambrell did
you have no okay all right so I guess we
will hold off on this one because it's
somewhat unclear whether um there's
still some open issues right so so this
might want to be amended and it might
want to be a bill ought to pass with
Amendment or it might want to be part of
house bill to right so um so maybe we'll
we'll wait on the rest of this one thank
you thank you
okay so we're going to wait on this
one all right now you've
done did we retain 619 if you want to um
the bills that we did we didn't execute
on any of them if you want to okay if
you want to go back and consider some
motions on those it's up to you yeah why
don't we do
that um so on my
bill as long as we're here can I make a
motion about to pass on House Bill
650 and I'll second that
motion oh and our oh is the housekeeping
is our clerk not ready
yes so I assume you talked about this
this is really just a housekeeping minor
thing
yeah so I moved at the pass
representative cell's second is that all
right I if if well I assume I I'll write
the blur right so
this that's that's the point of that one
okay um um any
discussion no sure yes ref um will this
have to go to a vote by the entire
finance committee oh yeah oh okay yeah
yeah this is just a Rec we just
recommend to the committee so everything
gets you know get to vote yeah okay
other questions no show of hands in
[Music]
favor okay any
opposed Jerry's not paying attention
he admits
it okay so he's in
favor okay very good thank you Mr clerk
okay 619 so this is a to pass okay yeah
it's not appropriate for house bill to
we'll just pass it as a bill
um uh 6 619 619 we were going to
recommend to retain retain there is an
amendment it'll probably come later but
so we can do it after we return okay oh
yeah and I want to talk more with the
committee about it anyway yes right
you're considering an amendment to put a
fee on it right yes okay good so you
want to make the
motion okay yeah you do it feels better
motion to uh retain the bill okay I'll
second okay so motion by representative
Ms to retain House Bill 619 seconded by
representative run
any discussion no okay all those in
favor raise your hands okay unanimous
excellent okay so that's
retained okay so we got that
164 um 164 local records
retention um there's an
amendment one with 100,000 Yes 120 so
they're going to be doing an amendment
to uh remove the cost because they have
a fund that's going to cover that no
that's a different one oh okay sorry I
jumped okay okay 164 should we just wait
on that
one
HB HB 164 there's um an amendment from
the sponsor in front of you that's
aligning the position request and the
funding but it does have an
appropriation so it's just a regular
appropriate something to do so maybe we
should retain this and consider for I
mean I'll I'll make the motion to retain
HB 164 okay all right and second by
represent all right motion by
representative evil to retain House Bill
164 seconded by representative rung any
questions any debate okay all those in
payer yes unanimous okay great okay
retain and we can consider the amendment
and so on but all this new spending is
not good all
right house bill 67 that's the one where
is an amendment coming so okay so we
should just wait that so represent
regard the amendment um may come but we
could also do it here LBA can do it just
because it's deleting section three
which is the appropriation and changing
the effective date for section 4 so if
it's something you were looking to take
action on we can vote um on the bill as
amended oh I see we can just sort of say
what we wanted in the amend yes that's
what we we've done and then when we get
to the full committee will'll have it
ready and correct it's a very straight
board Amendment he said something about
extending the pilot program through the
so he was just extending the effective
date yeah okay um which is section 4 to
1231 2025 and then deleting Section 3
which was the appropriation so I'll I'll
make a motion um or I'm recommend
mending ought to pass as amended and the
amendment would remove the $100,000
appropriation in the original Bill and
it would extend the effective date to
December 31st of
2025 I'll second that and and why are we
doing the extension because the
Secretary of State asked us to no but
make so gets time to get ready or
something for programming gotcha okay
all right so the motion is uh ought to
pass with Amendment the amendment would
remove section three from the bill and
change the effective date to December
31st
2025 do we have any
discussion no okay I'm G to trust you
on well we actually we talked quite a
bit while you were away and and
the she was here okay good all right so
all those in favor yes okay good another
unanimous excellent so you can put the
am my name on the amend all right so
eil all
right good so now that's everything
right that you guys have talked about
okay good so now we're back to we're
still waiting on 66 and
111 so how about uh
um how about
282 oh 282 we already talked no we
haven't oh yes we haven't talked about
282 okay let's do 282
then where is
it must be in
here is there anyone here to talk about
House Bill
282 representative
Pearson
yes you like
to I don't see it in my
list there it is there it
is
okay you are a co-sponsor okay so tell
us what this does sure thank you for the
record Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13 which encompasses
Dairy I am a co-sponsor of House Bill
282 so what 282 basically does is
there's a pool of money that exists it's
currently half a million in the event
that we have a critical injury situation
and it pays
for that
situation as time progresses and as I
certainly don't have to tell Finance the
cost of things go up
and what happens is the 500,000 isn't
what it used to be right
so
historically that fund has never
expended in in a given period more than
$375,000 so but let me give you a little
a little piece of reality so and I'll do
it on a on
a in a way that we all we all can apply
app to uh Interstate 93 you get a car
wreck we get two two fire engines which
is required there's a federal statute
now for that in an ambulance that will
put between eight and 10 people on the
highway unfortunately as we've all seen
on the news and in other videos um on
occasion drivers have plowed into those
events
so just
simply one event that was catastrophic
that 500 is gone like one event so the
concept here is that it takes that pool
of money that doesn't have to be
expended but is there and it puts it at
$1 million that that's the purpose of
that so that in the event of a
catastrophic event God forbid um it it's
there now again it's not I want to be
clear on something because I think there
was a little bit of confusion
um during the testimony on the floor of
the house this does not increase the
benefit to anyone specifically the
benefit ceiling stays exactly what it is
it this is just making the potential
pool of money available there in the
event that we have a more catastrophic
event that is the gist of this so I I I
know there seem to be some confusion
with some folks as to are we you know is
this is this a benefit that an
individual person is getting absolutely
not those limits all stay right where
they are it's just that we we're in
situation now where like I said
something simple on the highway and you
wiped out five people and here we are we
already exhausted it so um that that's
the ask that's the gist of it and um I
hope we never ever have to expend a
dollar out of it but
that's that's the premise of the bill
seems inevitable all right
representative Ms thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my questions um and
it it does seem re re relatively
straightforward particularly the way you
explained it the question I have for you
is when was the when's the last time
that the 125,000 per claim it was
adjusted that I cannot tell you I have
no idea and my I guess my point is that
you know as you mentioned $500,000 isn't
what it used to be neither is 125,000
did you consider sure raising that
amount per claimant I I think that
realistically um I would rather be able
to cover more people within the within
the pool of money than give an
individual a greater benefit because at
that point you're going to have to it
like I said if you've got a truck that
goes through an accident scene and and
by the way and I forgive forgive my my
colleagues that that wear the gun behind
me um I didn't even you know tally the
cops that that show up to this too I
just mentioned you fire an EMS Personnel
there's going to be a slew of Troopers
and um especially on the highway that
that may may or may not be involved um
or early on but definitely involved for
100% in the process so um you know
we're I would rather see six people
covered than four people covered better
if that makes sense I mean you know and
we can that's something that can be
looked at later on I I we didn't really
dive into that that part of it it was
just a matter of of sheer numbers and
and the unfortunate realities that are
going on
lately other questions representative
cell thank you Mr chair uh help me
understand the fund so why if somebody's
critically injured on the job I'm
assuming they all have insurance or uh
is this fund intended to like if they
didn't have insurance or didn't have
enough coverage why why wouldn't
insurances uh cover the this situation
so the yes if you're if you're in in
emergency response mode you are not a
freelance uh first responder so you are
working for an agency a municipality
either private or public most likely in
New Hampshire it's public but we do have
some private EMS um the workers comp
part of that if anybody here has ever
gone through that is a very long
complicated drawn out
arduous legal unfortunately battle that
occurs where you can have a someone who
basically is in in a state of limbo for
quite some time um you know I i' I've
sat for three terms on the PTSD
Commission we have
addressed um issues with that just the
the process you know and and I know it's
like well okay you're you're in uniform
you're on the highway you get hit by a
truck should be open and shut case with
workers comp and yet the initial letter
you'll receive from them is a denial and
that is some of that is a procedural
thing some of it has to do with just
timelines that exist but nothing in that
world moves quickly so these funds
assist with that um so that folks can
get moving forward I mean depending on
you might have to modify your house you
might have to put a ramp in you may not
have use of your legs you might I mean
there's there's some things that that
that goes to that
um that workers cop will eventually
catch up to but it takes time follow up
yeah follow up thank you um so I I
understand that um eventually when the
workers comp catches up and the
insurance catches up will the fund be
replenished I don't I am not aware of
that mechanism
existing why I why does that not happen
there's it's it's just another one of a
hundred questions that I ask about
workers comp that I do not understand
the logic um that
exists in their minds um because we have
we have situations where um workers comp
has
paid for something when a person was on
sick leave and the complexities actually
a matter of fact in the last PTSD
commission three weeks
ago we were told that the insurance
companies because they the question was
asked well if they're getting if that's
getting straightened out will that money
be returned to the insurance company and
we were told the insurance companies
have no mechanism to accept money which
I think is was the most shocking thing
I've ever heard that insurance company
has way of of being paid back so um
that that just as of right now
apparently doesn't
exist so so that basically lets them off
the hook the I I don't think it lefts
them off the hook we're talking about a
catastrophic injury who which claims are
in the
millions this by no means is bailing out
an insurance carrier or or anything like
that we're these are sub these are this
isn't just minor events that occur this
this fund is dedicated for catastrophic
events so yeah but yet it has occurred
so all those as you just stated all that
money that they should have paid back
has not been paid back we you don't know
the reason why but that's something we I
think we need to investigate so I don't
and I you know and if there's if there's
legislation in the future to address the
how that works I I would love to be uh
involved in it certainly because I it we
we scratch our heads on that you know it
just there's some there a disconnect
somewhere there no no doubt so Melissa
I'm assuming there's no dedicated fund
here that's holding $500,000 ready to
pay this it's just a source is the
general fund yeah yeah okay so and it
only come taken when when such an
incident happens so were we to pass this
bill there's probably no effect on on
the the budget
right unless it's utilized um I have a
message out right now trying to figure
out how that would work where that would
be recorded if there is an increase so
if that if there is an additional
$500,000 you say someone is injured
where does that show up in the line item
it wouldn't be on the Surplus statement
because not an appropriation but I do
want to just get clarification of how
that does impact I mean this is like we
have some other benefit of somebody
killed right and and we raised that
uh a while back but I don't know that we
added anything to the Surplus statement
because of we definitely would not add
anything to the Surplus statement yeah
yeah so yes rep representative Griffin
yeah I I just like I have many years
experience in Industry admittedly it
wasn't in the state it was in another
state but uh as a Chief Financial
Officer I got heavily involved in
workman comp claims and I found that the
insurance companies were very very
responsive to claims that were clearly
claims it's true if someone had a back
injury or something it got more drawn
out but we had cases where a truck
driver got on top of his truck fell down
between the load and the cab and managed
to expire trying to get out and um the
settlements were were very very fast we
had other cases where someone was badly
hurt on a job clearly in the hospital
with broken bones and things and the
response was very very fast it's true
when this cases someone says they strain
their
back they're a little slower but but I
think that's to be understood I just
want to I want to defend the companies a
little
bit very good good other questions for
representative Pearson no is there
anyone else here who would like oh did I
see one meliss okay I did get an answer
um so in the
statute a warrant would be drawn from
the governor If This Were to apply so we
don't need to worry about it in the
budget but that's that's how the money
transferred over I I would assume thank
you very much I do have one question for
you for you Mr chair um would it in the
future would it make sense I mean we
have
dedicated funds that that hold and I
know we don't there's a reluctance to to
just hold money for the sake of holding
money right I I know that um but if
there's concern about the ability to
draw this off
of general fund money would it make
sense to at some point create a fund
where a couple of these various items
that you mentioned have some money just
set aside well effectively that's what
the rainy day is for right and that has
at the moment that has 292 million but
okay so this would be eligible to be
drawn from the rainy day fund
essentially yes it would be okay all
right so we have it excellent thank you
okay very good anyone else here who
wanted to speak I see a hand in the back
there come come on
up thank
you good afternoon I'm Danielle Albert
I'm the Deputy Commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of Labor I promise
I will be brief I just thought I might
be able to answer some of the questions
that were raised relative to the workers
compensation system and how these
petitions um sort of funnel through and
and when the benefit applies um in the
first instance there had been a question
about the
$125,000 cap as representative Pearson
had noted um there there's no change in
this proposed language relative to that
cap I believe the question was whether
or not the cap had ever been adjusted it
has not the bill or the original um
version of this statute went into effect
back in 2014 and it's been at 125,000
since then um just sort of by way of
mechanism in the workers compensation
system itself this is an additional
benefit that gets paid to um First
Responders who have critical injuries
those petitions are filed through the
Department of Labor and on vetting of
certain criteria through the department
um a warrant can be drawn through the
governor's office for payout uh from
this particular fund and it's paid in
addition to other workers compensation
benefits so in order for a first
responder to be eligible for it they do
have to have a compens ible claim so
there's been some determination either
by the insurance carrier through the
Department of Labor that this is a work
injury that meets the stated standards
under the workers compensation law um
and it's paid in addition to um other
benefits cash benefits medical benefits
all of the other pieces um that come
along with having a workers's
compensation claim so I just thought I
would clarify the the process and the
procedure so we're probably not seeing
the whole law inside this bill but it
says that the payment to an individual
shall not exceed exed
$125,000 correct how is the payment
determined what the what the level is is
it based on the severity of the injury
or is it an excellent question so the
language that you're not seeing uh
included in the uh the proposed change
above that is a section where there is a
like I call it a statutory table so for
certain types of injury to um smell or
sensation or to soft uh certain types of
soft tissue organs there are a
prescribed number of weeks that are paid
for injuries of that nature for a
qualifying injury and that number of
weeks is um based on your compensation
rate so if I am the injured worker and
my compensation rate is uh $1,200 a week
and I have an injury that per that table
entitles me to 206 weeks it would be the
206 weeks times my compensation rate to
determine the amount of the benefit
that's paid if it ex if the amount of
the benefit on that calculation exceeds
the10 $5,000 the cap applies if it's
underneath it then it's the total
calculation gotcha okay very good so any
other questions no so I I tend to think
that this is is a just an not to pass um
Everybody sort of agreeing with that
yeah okay so who would like to make a
motion representative MS2
okay I'll second that motion second okay
very good any other discussion no um all
right uh all those in
favor yeah
unanimous all right
easy very good all right Mr chairman yes
can I request that we Rec are you guys
reconsider House Bill 67 as what was
done with the amendment is it's more
technical than what was actually stated
and representative paig is here to
further explain and I have a version of
that Amendment okay all right um all
right
so um would you like to make a motion of
reconsideration 67 House Bill 67 I'll
make a motion to reconsider House Bill
67 I'll second it second it all right
rep representative cells moves to
reconsider House Bill 67 seconded by
representative eel all those in in favor
please raise your
hands okay any opposed
no he's in favor okay he's just slow all
right unanimous so let's see what
happened here
okay oh
there the effective date became a
different two effective dates one for
section two and one for everything else
or something like that so previous still
don't see removing section
three yeah where is the
so oh I see replace all after section
one exactly yeah yeah
yeah okay and previously if you left in
section two the pilot program would have
been repealed gotcha oh I
see all right now are we happy yes all
right and can I just ask yes go
ahead uh the Secretary of State's office
is fine with this
amendment yes I I have email from
secretary from um deputy secretary
Hennessy indicating that she's fine with
with this
Sor I start over yeah so would you like
to make a motion I
will thank you very much Mr chair um I'd
like to make a motion that um
hb67
FNA uh the do you want me to make a
motion on the amendment first or just do
well I would just say they ought to pass
with Amendment okay ought to pass with
Amendment um
H okay how
okay okay all
right so does everybody understand the
new changes why we're doing it this way
instead of the way we did it
before yes represent run thank you Mr
chair um so the amendment is essentially
strike
or it's replacing all after section one
but if you look at line
14 um it's there there's the the bill
makes it it deletes the words a pilot
program but would that language would
that that that wording still be struck
no that's part of section one section
one goes from line one I see line 19 all
right I was looking at Roman numeral
yeah okay thank you I always have
trouble okay
discussion no okay so all those in favor
of ought to pass with Amendment
0788 all right that's unanimous very
good
okay thank
you don't come
back okay so this is
octopus Amendment
0781 h
yeah
okay ah so they were here the dogs were
here for the
accessible okay very good all right good
so
um so the only one would we're waiting
for now all right so this was is
representative Lynn and I had made a
deal with him to meet at three so should
we go back to house bill two and see if
there's things
right he representative Lynn would be
here for both House Bill 66 and House
Bill five minutes oh take a take a
little break okay yeah let's take a a
five minute break yes did we take action
on
216 216 we retained it I believe is that
right or did we yeah we voted on okay
yeah okay so so we'll take a break until
quarter of
for
e
e e
oh because of the money because of the
money right let it
lapse right well anyways what what are
we talking about let's let's turn to
page
43 of house bu
to just to have the
discussion all right
um so I guess Melissa do or Jack do we
know if any of this money has been spent
so far or
no on housing Champion designation and
grant program
fund so I believe when Bea came in um I
don't think they they were finishing up
the rules they were in the application
process they had some of it earmarked
for um for some of the grants to be paid
out but they hadn't officially been paid
out yet
M so so this is extending it right
another year with the assumption that
they were going to use the full
amount we're talking about on House Bill
two page
43 line
12 okay item number 72 section
72 so this is we we appropriated $5
million from a uh in the budget last
year two years ago and um we we gave
them until June 30th the end of the bium
to spend the money afterwards it would
lapse well here we are the money's not
been spent so the governor wants to give
them an extra
year but I'm
thinking I'm thinking no right I mean
you know
um we need the money
so this is big bucks but you know they
or it lights a fire under them and they
spend it by June 30th right so that's
the the other possibility I I mean I'd
be disinclined just because I think
there's an awful lot of people counting
on housing
money um but inec system yeah well we
don't know yet right because
yeah and that's probably why they still
have the money because they're still
well they said they were making rules
and they were doing this having rules
so I don't know Mista have they spent
any of the money just for administrative
and all that I can I can check with them
again I think when they came in they
said they hadn't at that point um the
the program was created in hb2 in 2020
23 so the program was created the uh the
expenditure I mean the appropriation was
also put in there and then just because
of that delay but I can that's a fair
question and I can follow up with them
just to make sure
um we'd have to get the money anyways
for the Surplus statement to see what's
been what will lapse and what hasn't
been lapsed because the only thing that
will lapse is what uh hasn't already
been expended has already been spent
spended or incumbered yeah right and
that can happen before the end of the
year thank that's accurate so in any
case I mean we put in a date before you
know just cuz they haven't spent it
that's on them I think all right but we
can we can move on for now let's see um
are there any easy ones
here um page 25 how about the ohrv
trails do we know anything about that is
that the Connecticut River I think
that's division
two it's on my
oh
really page 25 sections 23 and
24 if they took over the trails they
would be able to keep it over few more
weeks which would bring more Revenue to
the
area right so this is um
moving the the closure date of the
trails a little longer I have sworn we
had a bill on this did yeah in the past
right
County delegation saying have Sheriff
take it over fish game cling a of It
kind of intersection
so off the already fixed oh I see so
maybe we can take this out because it's
already in a bill do we know the bill I
know she's she she's madly looking
yeah so it looks like it's HB
127 quick searches
it looks like it's it's the same bill
yeah that's what I thought it look it's
the same
yeah yes okay and the bill passed and
you waved it off so we can
just
right fish game
okay this
is so why don't we just take this out
then it did it was it like on the
consent calendar or something or uh so
it was ought to pass
um 198 to 180
[Music]
it's
controversial yes it it has that ring to
it but it's already but it already pass
but if you don't like it then we don't
want it in house built too right that's
what I was thinking I mean it's already
passed so either way we might as well
take it out I mean we might the guy from
county and
say take care of the same problem well
you looked at you just looked at it it's
the same language yes yeah okay all
right so so let's take it out so who
wants to make a motion to remove
sections 23 and 24 I'll I'll do it I'll
make the motion to remove sections 23
and 24 from the from hb2 I'll second the
motion okay mov and second by
representative eil to remove sections 23
and 24 seconded by representative camls
all those in favor please raise your
hand okay good we cross that one out
seven
gone
okay um what else any other easy ones
here
um State
commission take a yeah bail you want to
do bail
I think we gotta wait for a bill right
on that one what's boat house yeah oh
boat houses that's probably Dees they're
coming on Friday right right okay so
yeah
wa where did that even come
from I don't know to be
continued about elevator feet
penalty 61 oh was that labor
maybe he wanted to put his dentist chair
in
it okay did we have we talked about the
treasuries ones page 64 no that's good
those are probably easy
okay page 64 is it right at the bottom
oh I see section section
153 Benjamin yes trust fund yeah so this
is a fund that's being moved to um it's
all it does is benefit UNH and the the
university system and so what we're
going to do here is is move the the
funds to their endowment and let them
handle it directly because otherwise
it's just been building up and building
up and
um uh they're not getting as much money
as they could uh if you know without the
middleman aspect of it so yes
representative R thank you so Mr chair a
question I have is
it's it's relative to the Benjamin
Thompson trust fund are repealed but
does that the other statues will that
then direct it to be under the
University Foundation no what what's
happening is the because it's a it's a a
trust um the AG has to go to to probate
court and get the money moved and so
that's part of this whole process all
right so it's not going to that's that
piece isn't covered under legislation
then apparently not okay thank you yeah
I make a motion to keep this one in yeah
hp2 okay I'll second it okay I'll second
it all right good so um motion by
representative cambrell to keep section
153 of House Bill 2 second by
representative eel all those all those
in favor yeah okay good so we will keep
that one I think let's let's look at the
next one so budget and Appropriations
revolving funds
um volum
classes death service shall not lapse
that sounds like a good idea yeah I
think she was just putting in law what
should be what she does yeah okay all
right I'll make I'll make the motion to
retain or to keep in hb2 section
154 okay um motion by representative eil
to keep House Bill 2 Section 154
seconded by representative rung all
those in favor yeah unanimous good uh
with represent a Ms missing so we
keeping that
one
okay uh Revenue
sharing oh no this one I want to look at
actually yeah we put this in every year
this 31a hasn't been paid out for
decades mhm that's true I've tracked it
but we always put it in here because
what we ought to do is maybe just repeal
that of suspending yeah repal RSA 31
yeah I want to I'd actually
like to spend a little time reading this
because I have the I have in mind that
this might be a better way to return
rooms of meals money to towns than the
one we do now so what we do now is is
strictly based on population so um like
the town of success which has two people
and $15 million worth of
property2 and the mount carbury landfill
yeah right what right the property is
this landfill right and so in Success
New Hampshire in Success New Hampshire
yeah but because they have that anyways
the point is we we send them
$200 from the rooms of meals tax when
they got all the property in the world
right so so this might be a better way
of doing it I think and and since it's
already exists do you know what this me
I think it has something to do with
property value per
person okay as opposed to just number of
people do you know but I I I haven't
read it so let let's wait on this one
she's I can't tell if she know if she
knows the answer or not it's a
complicated formula but representative
Maguire is correct in in the premise
that it is based on um Equalization of
the property and how many people live in
the town yeah so it and it's you know
it's already there in law
so
yeah
everybody
people that's
right yeah so let me let me um take a
look okay so this is RSA
we will wait on this one
31a so um he's still not here Mr still
here yes could I just I don't know where
you are in your list but what is the
effect of section 156 regarding it was
repeal regarding Wastewater state aid
grants because we there there's a whole
bunch
of water related stuff
here right but this particular one has
to do with the it's I thought it had to
do with the Buco Buck thing so I don't
are they repealing are they getting rid
of the money I I don't understand what
the import of that is it's very short
but are you talking doesn't carry a big
stick 156 is it section 156 so 156 is
what you termed I'm going to do quotes
uh termed Buco bucks uh the Senate put
that 15 million that's requested each
year 15 million um for the BM the Senate
put it in their budget last year um last
budget so they pre-funded the program we
typically we have never pre-funded the
program the bill comes up which is why
it's termed Buco buck as representative
Buco typically sponsors the bill uh
again the Senate last budget put the
money in the governor um has chose to
remove those dollars and repeal that
statute I I thought it looked short and
carried a big stick so that's basically
putting how much money back into 15 uh
15 million yeah do you remember
when oh I I remember but I mean I I also
remember when they were sitting here
talking about this how important the
money was to them well but yes but what
I'm saying is when when Dees was here
they gave us that little spreadsheet
that said we had so much this year and
so much next year and and and we're
subtracting this and this is what's left
over
that's this one yes so let's see what's
left 15 million per year so 30 million
over theum we'll go back to the looking
because they pre-funded it so it's not
got a bunch of anyway
I this is we'll think about it it's a
big
deal oh yeah and you had to repl Y I
know that bypass that didn't get
built all right well let's Melissa let's
make a note to ask them about this on
Friday and uh figure out how much uh
money is in this line in this section
it's 15 it's 15 million for the bium
it's 15 million per year it's 30 million
for the bium it's a straight
appropriation that was in hb2 in 2023 so
it's a straight General none of it has
been correct right they don't get they
don't get it until um July 1 2026 so
they're basically defunding the state
aid grant but
we6 we've retained this similar bill as
well in in the division but that's the
but that's the the upshot of this
provision yeah right that's it so it's
30 m no wonder the governor had so much
revenue so well this I think I I
actually hadn't seen this before I think
this is a new
addition I don't know this was in this
was also in the trailer bill I didn't
see it before yeah so small said it's
small and carries a big stick yes yeah
so this would be for for new funding
going forward they do have in their
budget they've already budgeted for the
the payments that they've already um
committed to the municipality so this is
above and beyond for new for new
projects okay we'll have to talk to them
about that yeah so is there should we go
down this list or is it whatever want to
do Mr chair yeah uh monitoring Wells I
mean these are things I was going to
wait to talk to thees about right
because these are all their things right
that's fine I I just didn't understand
wanted to make sure I understood the
import of that I'm sorry if I went out
of order yeah well that's okay um oh
here's something for a dollar a
dollar oh yeah well oh Mr chair yes
represent um thank you in
157 I read that as just saying they've
gotten more precise in their measurement
and to provide consistent International
terminology on the metrics so rather
than using de um decimal minutes going
to decimal degrees before it was degrees
and decimal minutes I don't think you I
think internationally the accepted
measurement for GPS coordinates is under
decimal degrees and I'm excited they can
bring it out to five decimal places
that's pretty good all right I'm
concerned that it shouldn't be that it
should be six okay all right so
representative rung moves to accept
Section
157 want want to second that I'll second
it seconded by representative evil any
further
discussion no okay all in favor yes
okay uh almost
unanimous okay unanimous very good so
we're going to keep section 157
done
[Music]
um okay I wanted to there was another
one that looked it might be easy here
162 16 how about I go backwards to um
here's one we wanted to raise fees right
so at
137 page I'm sorry page
61 we didn't get the
number what's that weren't we going to
get input from them on that
amount of the elevator of the Fe
I don't think I don't
know
um so um so this is the the elevator
fee and um what this says they're
changing it so they'll actually collect
the
fee because you know how every elevator
has a certificate in it right so so what
this says is current the current
practice is uh they inspect the elevator
they give you the certificate you owe
$50 and if you don't pay your
certificate is now invalid well guess
what you already got
it right so now what this says is
they'll inspect the elevator they'll
give you an invoice for $50 you pay the
$50 and then they'll send you the
certificate right which makes
sense so the question is the only
question here is do we want to changed
the $50 to $100 or something some other
number right that was so the one we
heard needed yes yeah they had broken
broken back I mean I I thought they were
going to give us a recommendation on the
fee change all right so you want to wait
okay we have we asked the Department of
Labor for possibilities of more fees in
this I thought we did we should I think
we did but I'll I'll follow up with them
follow up and see CU tell them we're
thinking of making it $100 the other
thing is I would rewrite this so that
the the the fee is only in the sentence
one
time right so not that it's the same fee
repeated three times because that that
doesn't make sense okay now how often
they how often do they inspect I think
it's annual it says here right
[Music]
um is it um that's when they lug the 50
pound weights yeah it's it's I believe
it's annual
um but uh I think I read that elsewhere
in the
law why you think it should be every two
years you want to raise the fee oh I see
be right and so yeah I mean if it it's
if it's an annual inspection and and you
change it to buy to buy anual then you
need half as many inspectors right so
well we'll see and charge twice as much
it's it's pretty bad though if an
elevator goes crashing to the ground so
we'll have to see what they think about
the inspection
rate cost of the truck drag
2000 and and and physical therapy for
people's backs that have lug the we I
mean so this is the right answer right
we should figure out how much are the
inspectors costing us how much are they
raising in fees and match the two
right to pay for the truck and all that
stuff okay representative Sweeney had
suggested that my notes here that before
we just arbitrarily set fees we really
ought to know how much it cost yeah yeah
okay very good all right now we're going
to go back to bills since I I see
representative Lynn
here
so let's go to House Bill 66
does that make sense the first
one uh representative Lynn would you
like to talk about House Bill
66 and if you need a copy
of okay
okay so
um I guess
um I'm sorry I put the I guess I'm I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
may have I
think my my sense is that
the the majority of the things that
the um that this bill does you know the
I mean the main reasons why I I I think
it was enacted or I mean it was it was
proposed and then passed you know the
house on the policy side was was just to
um to to uh more closely comply with the
uh
with with the idea of of O government
being open and to so for example it
changes citizen to person that's one
that's probably one of the big uh one of
the big uh uh things that this bill
accomplishes um it has a
provision um that
allows
um uh with regard to
um with regard to somebody who has a
connection with New Hampshire uh either
as a taxpayer or owns property or
whatever um that they're allowed to get
um uh information under the right to no
law they like they're allowed to request
it electronically and to and to have it
provided electronically and they can
basically request the format that it's
provided in and as long as the town you
know as long as it's reasonable for the
town to provide that it won't cost uh uh
it won't interfere with their
recordkeeping system or cause some
security problem s for their system they
have to they have to provide it in that
format and then if it's somebody that
doesn't have a New Hampshire connection
or is not a member of the media then the
law sort of Remains the Same as it was
you can come to the town you can come to
the town and ask for the in I mean you
can ask for the information and the T if
you come to the town's officers and
candidly as I think I I I know I we
discussed this during the hearing that
was that was sort of a compromis because
there were I think legitimate concerns
by municipalities that if we didn't draw
that distinction you know theoretically
uh somebody Jammy somebody from Beijing
Jammy surfing uh you know and bored
about what to do at night could say GE I
wonder if I could get all the email
Communications from uh the town of
Brentwood and uh and they'd have to
provide they'd have to provide it
whereas if you say to that person sure
come on you know come on in our offices
are open from whatever to whatever uh
and I'll I'll I'll be happy to give the
flight information from getting from
Beijing to uh to Brentwood that may tend
to discourage people I see okay um so
that's you're talking about stuff on
page two where it says shall not be
required to Pro provide electronically
and things like that
yeah it looks like there's some concern
from the the judicial
branch in the fiscal
note yeah hang on just expanding the
right so so did you get a sense that
that people are who are currently not
served are sort of beating down the door
here or is this kind of a Dem Minimus I
sort of thing my you know the what we
heard during the during the during the
he the hearings before the Judiciary
Committee I think was
largely um you know
uh concerns about like what could have
was this somehow going to be too broad
what could happen that kind of thing
um I I I know I remember um someone from
the school administrators uh Association
saying that you know they they could
recall a couple of instances where for
example some company in California
wanted to get some records uh and I
don't even remember frankly off hand
what the records were but some records
from a school district that would be
that that would give them information
that they could use for marketing
purposes I don't I don't remember
exactly what it was but it was some
information and the you know the guy
from the uh uh the representative from
the school uh School Board Association
said you know typically what a school
district would would would do in that
situation is say you know those records
are available just come to our offices
and you can get it and his response was
most of the time the people who have
made that request don't want it that
badly that they're willing to do that um
and so it's not you know it's not a big
issue I just I should just say on that
point an earlier version of this bill
would have allow would not have drawn
the distinction between the you know do
you have a New Hampshire connection or
not it would it would have allowed
somebody in California or China as I
said to just ask for the records and
have have them have to be provided
electronically gotcha Melissa wanted to
say something or so there was a revised
fiscal note that you should have for 228
since the introduced Bill expanded the
scope the judicial branch anticipated
there could be more cases but since the
amended bill just keeps it within New
Hampshire that changes okay so it it
made it smaller yeah right okay
yeah I see him okay he might like to say
something in a minute okay now the other
the only change I like I wanted to make
to this bill is on page two line
17 so there's a sentence which is now
says um citizen initi initiated appeal
shall have no filing fee or sear charge
you're changing that to all appeals have
no filing fear or sir charge what if we
take that out because we're asking uh
the courts to um to increase fees and
and fines and and sort of generate more
money um and so this this thing about
being able to appeal with no appeal the
ombudsman's ruling with no
cost um doesn't doesn't make sense to me
so I'm thinking about can we take out
that cour
um so in words you go back to you you
want to go back to Citizen initiated is
that there or you just want to take that
out make it make the citizen and
everybody else have to pay have to pay
the filing fee just like anybody who
wants to go to the superior right um so
here's what I here's here would be my
response to that first of all as I think
I as I mentioned to you Mr chair when in
our conversation earlier this
morning I I I completely understand that
the budget is we have a very difficult
situation with the budget and and
frankly I am in complete agreement with
with you and I hope the committee that
that's got to be the first priority is
you know having a a fiscally responsible
budget and if that means Cuts then that
means cuts and if that means pain then
that means pain I completely agree with
that um so I I you know I um from that
perspective I if if the if the committee
feels that that's what we need what
needs to be done um that's fine I can I
certainly can live with that what i' say
is the idea I think the idea of this was
as you may recall last year and then
really again this year there was this
huge fight and it was a bipartisan fight
there we had you know Republicans and
Democrats on both sides of it how much
should municipalities or you know other
people that get other bodies that get
records request should they be able to
charge for it how much should they be
able to charge for it um you know that
whole thing and as part of the sort of
there was a compromise worked out um
that you know that limited the the the
situations in which municipalities could
charge um and there was some language
ated about being able to get an estimate
and have the the Ombudsman uh review
that and then appeal and I think the
whole this
this language that provides no filing
fee or or search charge for the appeal
was part of the sort of compromise that
we would make it easier for people to be
able to get review of the decisions I on
you know I think it's do I think that's
a good idea as a you know in the in the
abstract sure is it worth it if you if
it's going to cost money that the this
committee thinks you shouldn't have no
you should you should do what you think
is right representative
Griffin yeah it it seems to me if if we
uh put a fee in there people are going
to say well if I lose to the Omnibus
then I'm going to have to pay a fee to
go to the court and then I'm going to
have to pay a fee at the court and uh it
seems to me the you're creating a
motivation not to go the easy route not
to go to the Omni buzzman but to go
directly to court
no I mean there there's something to
that I think you I think that's a that's
a valid that's a valid point I agree
with that all right represent Ms then
thank you Mr chair thank thanks for
coming in the the other change that you
that's made in this bill is on page one
uh line 17 where we include preliminary
drafts right um in um you know in in the
the list of things that they have a
right to request what's the back ground
in that have there been issues and you
know I I you my first reaction is oh my
God that's going to create the an
enormous recordkeeping challenge no you
know what actually the that although
it's new putting the language in there
is new it's not that's not a change of
existing law existing law in another
section I it's another section of the
rights to no law covers preliminary
drafts that are circulated to a major to
a you know a majority or a quorum of a
of a body are already under existing law
subject to being uh subject to the right
of no law so you might say well okay if
that's true why'd you put it in here
that was that was representative
Edward's recommendation because he
thought that it by by sort of repeating
it right here um it would emphasize that
point and make it uh you know M put it
in a in a place where it was even more
obvious than where it is in because I it
is it is wherever it is in the other
section right now it's not quite as
obvious so um he thought it was
important I said Hey listen may it it it
I I see your point and that's what we
did I you know the analogy he drew is
you may you may recall when we passed
the uh uh the fetal Life protection act
the original version didn't have a
certain certain language about uh in one
section uh but it had it in another and
we and there was a big fight about that
we moved it so it's in both sections and
that seemed to address that issue so I
think that's what he was thinking about
gotta uh represent rung thank you Mr
chairman yeah I'm tagging on that line
17 on page one preliminary drafts
circulated to a quorum or a majority of
the public party I mean I I I hear what
you're saying that it's already in stat
statute someplace else but and I know
we're really just dealing with fiscal
impacts but first of all preliminary
drafts is that defined somewhere it
almost seems redundant like wouldn't a
draft be
preliminary um and a drafts of what like
drafts of anything schedules well
reports schedules something like that I
mean I think you know my understanding
is I I I think the people that are
heavily involved in you know in you know
municipalities and stuff I mean they
sort of know if you don't want if you
don't want something to be subject to
disclosure under the rights of no law
don't circulate it to a quorum of the
committee you know have a have a have a
discussion uh you know among less than a
quorum but once you circulate it to the
Quorum it's really it's now covered by
the right to
NOA okay so it would really be any
document circulated oh yeah no I think
it could be right I could if a documents
get circulated I mean you know unless
it's confidential under some other
provision of the law um if it's if it
gets circulated it's subject to
disclosure okay other questions
representative Sweeny thank you and I I
I'm sorry I don't want to really weit
into policy here but just based off of
what we were just discussing I know in
the legislature we have caucus
protections for 91a so even if you had a
majority of the body is in one caucus
that communication is protected right
there there's no such thing locally not
at the no because because mostly you
know there's not it's there's not in
most place they're not elected as
Republicans Or democrats and so yeah
that's uh that's right that's right all
right all right so um I guess you're G
to wait for 111 in a moment one house
bill there's a second bill that sure 111
is uh yeah oh okay representative eel
another question I I just wanted to ask
since the Ombudsman is here if he had
any comments yeah I'll do that I I I
will I'm on top of that okay but you're
going to represent Lynn you'll you'll
stay for a minute oh absolutely of
course I will AB course officer yarus is
this the bill you wanted to talk about
okay would you come up
please
no
sorry thanks please introduce yourself
well first thanks for having me uh
Lieutenant Jared y Manchester Police
Department I'm in charge of the uh legal
and Professional Standards division I'm
here uh to speak on behalf of my agency
and the chiefs of police uh first and
foremost without without a doubt we
understand the importance of
transparency in law enforcement right
and building the trust of the public and
working hand inand with them um but the
fiscal uh the financial uh issues that
come up just simply with the to start
with with 91a and right to know alone is
crippling to municipalities specifically
law enforcement agencies because I would
probably guess that we probably get more
91a requests than most other agencies
because we do things that are often
interesting right we're involved in
critical incidents that people want to
know about uh so you know just to give
you some context last year alone in 2024
my agency handled over 1400 right to
know requests right now this is an
unfunded mandate uh placed on our agency
so its task is a collateral duty to
myself uh but due to the large influx of
numbers of requests you can see I also
have it tked out to 10 other records per
in my agency we have the luxury luxury
in my agency to have large numbers right
it's absolutely crippling though to
these smaller agencies that don't have
the luxury of these numbers the reason
being is you know obviously the current
climate with hiring it's difficult to
get Personnel it's realistic to believe
that these guys are pulling individuals
off the road officers off the road in
order to handle the influx of these
requests right and when we're doing that
we're taking officers off the road right
and when we take officers off the road
we lose that police presence right that
presence that deters crime and uh so
when we look at currently some of the
issues that are going to arise with the
um Amendment here uh is you I'll start
with the uh the electronic uh
dissemination of these right and we look
at the fact that we're probably going to
open ourselves up to a significant
number of more requests from out uh
outside the state
um
[Music]
the issues that we'll see here is in the
second page here in paragraph uh four
where it talks about um you know doile
have a domiciled in New Hampshire owns
property uh in New Hampshire pays New
Hampshire taxes right um as law
enforcement say how are we vetting this
information how are we proving that you
have a business here in the state right
if we're going to do that that's going
to continue to tax us right there right
because now I'm going to have to utilize
some type of personnal to look into this
and say is John Doe an actual taxpayer
are you know do they actually have a
business in this state right and second
off when we're doing this right there is
anonymity that some people do like to
request under for this you know when
they're dealing with law enforcement
which is understandable right um so we
have to look at those factors
um I don't want to take up too much of
your time right
um the other thing we got to look at too
is with um records not all our records
are uh electronic right so if you're
going to have to disseminate these
rically these records are going to have
to be located they're going to have to
be scanned in not everything is kept uh
in digital format and Records Management
Systems um we're still only in its
infancy in law enforcement uh with
implementing technology that's the
reality of it um and lastly some of my
other concerns are is just these blanket
requests that we do receive and proving
that they are an actual person right we
do have to deal with Technologies such
as Ai and Bots where we will see blanket
requests that go out throughout the
state where they asking for information
and realistically what they're trying to
do is hope that they get that agency
that didn't take the time to review that
paperwork and they go and release
someone's private information right and
every single request that does come in
through our agency we treat uh with this
you know the same amount of interest
because we do have an uh duty to protect
the privacy of uh individuals right we
understand that there's a duty for uh
you know provide public interest but we
also have to protect privacy um and
again that
leads to again a significant amount of
Manpower and ours um that's really all I
have right now on that okay representive
L thank thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in and thanking thank you for
your service to our community
um so the existing the existing law says
every citizen and and the proposal is to
change it to any person I'm assuming
that citizen is easier for you to verify
is that one of is that fair to say so
the guidance that we utilize is that um
our agency will ask you come and
retrieve those documents in person and
by simply you showing up in person we
treat that as a citizen we don't pull
your ask for your ID we don't ask for
anything to that effect um part of that
is um almost a survival mechanism that
agencies are utilizing right now so that
they can cut down on the number of uh
Records that they have to disseminate
because they can't keep up um when it
comes to how other agencies are checking
to confirm if they're a citizen I'm
unsure but we my agency does not check
anything simply you being president in
person we treat you as
citizen represent of evil all I was
going to say is that the word person in
New Hampshire law has a very
broad it's not just people it's it can
be entities it could be all sorts of
things it's not just a person so it's
quite an
expansion other questions no did you um
take your concerns to the Judiciary
Committee on this bill I did not I was
not present for that I'm sorry okay all
right very good and um so you said
you're doing uh 1,400 requests a year so
that's like six a day roughly I guess is
yes yeah okay and how much time does it
take to process a typical request or do
you have a sort of an hours man hours
per year kind of no and that will vary
depending on requests and who's
requesting it and uh uh for instance I
have requests that I've been working on
for uh four or five months now um simply
because the sheer volume of those
requests where other ones are pretty
simple hey I need this document um okay
I pull the document I'm able to redact
it it's easily found and I can get it
back to them within 15 20 minutes but uh
on average there I would say um you know
you're looking at anywhere from an hour
to two hours handling minimum some of
these um and again the sheer volume and
size of some of the requests uh that we
see are just astronomical gotcha okay
thank you very much other questions
don't see any thank you for coming um
and we do see the utsman here would you
like to weigh in on House Bill
66 maybe on the other one thank you
thank you
officer absolutely
to the extent that the officer come up
come up so you turn on the microphone
and all that stuff sorry representative
Lyn again to the extent that the officer
was concerned about like if they don't
have records
electronically but the request is made
for them to be provided electronically I
think the bill says they don't have to
do that if the if the records don't ex
if there's only hard copies of the
records then the then the the town can
say can say you know we're not going to
we're not going to convert them to
electronic it's only if they exist in
electronic form that then you have to
provide them that way now does this bill
change the fact that a person would have
to request in person and and now they
will be able to request online yes in
other words right now now right now the
town can say you got to come in and
request in person this would say if you
have a New Hampshire connection or
you're a member of the media you don't
have to come in you can ask remote you
can request remotely and the town had
and you and if you know and you can say
I'd like to get the records
electronically and if the town has it
electronically they have to respond
electronic and so presumably your
committee talked about this and decided
that that that wasn't unreason I mean
the the the openness aspect outweighed
whatever that right that that was I mean
we you know we were
not
considering um to the extent that you're
going to consider the the financial
aspect of this I mean we I'm not saying
we we didn't have that you know we
weren't considering it at all but but
not to the same extent that you are okay
very good representative evil and then
representative thank you am I not
correct that the word person is much
broader in New Hampshire law than the
word citizen I I think you're right I
think you know yeah no no I think you're
right I I guess UND but I don't know if
you're aware of the where what the
impetus for this change was that well
there was a case in uh involving a
request for information
by uh in uh from to the town of
Rochester and it was made by a
recognized uh media person who who
provides you know media in provides
media U I think it's a maybe a podcast
or it might even be a newspaper in
Rochester to the citizens of Rochester
but the person lives in
so he made a me he made a 91a request
for information from Rochester they
refused to give it to him saying he's uh
he's he's not a citizen and we don't
have to give it and in fact I think
there if I recall correctly their
position was you had to be a citizen of
the M of whatever the jurisdiction was
so he had to be a citizen of Rochester
so the media guy couldn't get his stuff
if that went to the Superior Court super
Court said that's baloney I mean which
correctly in my view that is just
complete baloney and pointed out that
there has as far and the court did a
pretty good job of research on this
apparently there had never been a case
before this in which the issue of you
know of somebody denying a request on
the basis of citizenship was ever made
was not just never was done um but
nonetheless that was enough of an alarm
I mean particularly where it was a media
person it was enough of an alarm that I
think we thought you know we we ought to
change this but that's still a human
being I I I think in New Hampshire law
person has a broader meaning and we can
look into that a little bit more but
there are many statutes where this term
where the word person is used and it's
not just human beings there oh I no I
agree completely so I mean I guess so
that's a broadening Beyond right because
here it just says
citizen yeah although I'm not sure that
you know C I mean I'm I'm not sure that
that would be limited to human being
either I mean is a a corporation I if a
corporation is is New Hampshire
Corporation is that a citizen of New
Hampshire certainly not for voting
certainly not for voting but I mean for
other purposes uh that's a good it's a
it's a question though because it's
definitely a a oh no it is sure it is a
question clearly if some person who
worked for a company wanted you know if
if we somehow disallowed the company
from from making a request any person
that that company could come in and make
the request right so what difference do
that make all right so I think
representative Rong and then
representative cell thank you Mr
chairman so I'm looking on uh page two
line nine it says that the public body
or agency shall not be required to
provide records electronically if it
lacks the technological capability to do
so if doing so would be unduly
burdensome or if doing so would
compromise the security of its
recordkeeping system after listening to
the officer's testimony my concern um I
get my my question is if let's say a a
police officer has to go back and redact
information that's on an electronic
document would that be then considered
unduly burdensome so they wouldn't have
the requirement of having to provide
that electronically because I could see
where they may have a a scan of a police
report or some type of investigation
document and they want to keep um some
identities confidential if they if that
document's being requested and they have
to go back and redact the electronic
version would would you consider that to
be defined as a burdensome to provide
that do that document no I would say I
would say I mean no un I mean unless if
it was a request for you know I want I
want like every uh I want every police
report that was issued by the city of
Manchester in the last six months
sure I think that would be burdensome
but if it was just you know I want to I
want a some particular police report and
the police have to go through and redact
it to you know to uh exclude
confidential information no I would
think I think that kind of thing happens
really all the time that they you know
that police or not just police
particularly police maybe but other
agencies have to make redactions before
they provide information I think that
happens all the time okay thank you
representative cambrell thank you Mr
chair
if a uh person makes a request for an
electronic record and the electronic
record cannot be provided because they
don't have it electronically does the
person then have to pay for hard copies
to be generated the yeah well they have
yes they can be charged um the I uh I
think there's somewhere else in the
statute I believe that says you know
that it's not subject to this amendment
I believe it but I believe they can be
charged for the copying costs to to uh
you know to per page or whatever to copy
the records and then they can also be
charged if they have whatever the it
costs to mail it to the person uh who
who requested it okay so even though
they had requested an electronic copy
which should be free they still have to
pay for the copying cost because it's
not available that way right if in other
words if it is if it is they can't you
know they can't sort of if it is
available electronically then they have
to provide it electronic but if it's not
they don't have to then they they can
say no we don't have it you have to it's
only hard copy and you have to pay for
the hard copy thank you represent Ms did
you have a question um yes uh thank you
uh on on page um I guess it's page one
uh lines 29 and 30 it it reads at the
election of such person requesting the
records the public body or agency shall
provide such electon such records
electronically or by
mail does that does that give the agenc
see in the case of the officer's example
the Manchester Police Department the
option to decide that they do not want
to provide it
electronically or if or if the if the
person coming in says they want it
electronically are they required to do
it electronically no I think they're you
know what I think they are required to
provide it um electronically
uh oh where is it I I thought there was
something else in here that says that
um uh copy means uh
chronically the election it does seem a
little confusing oh no so I'm sorry but
you know what it says at the election
the important thing is uh on line 24 any
person may request governmental records
electronically or by mail without
physically appearing then B I think the
important language there is at the
election of the person requesting the
records but then it goes on to say the
public body or agency shall provide such
records electronically or by mail right
but in other words that but it's but
it's at the they they can provide it one
way or the other at the election okay of
the person that's making the request so
if the person making the request says I
want it electronically and you have it
electronically you then you have to
provide it that way okay thank you
represent W did you have usually on this
subject the complaint we hear is from
the Town Clerk and the local Crank that
comes in almost every week and demands
hundreds of pages and and uh you know
doesn't want to pay for them and just
keeps coming back and asking for more
I'll ask if anybody else and I thought
that was going to change this by saying
you know people are too frequent or or
too burdensome representative wild i i
as you may recall from last year we had
a huge fight on this and I have to say
I'm on your side I would I was one of
those saying they should have more the
town should have more ability to charge
but there was a hug huge you know view
on the other side and as I say it was
bipartisan it wasn't Republican Democrat
there were people on both
sides there was a compromise reached and
you know it was I so that's kind of
where we are all right thank you
representative Lynn so we we're gonna is
anyone else like to weigh in on um House
Bill 66 oh oh another one oh you want to
come back okay and the municipal
okay well let's let's all right let's
start with
you good afternoon I'm Margaret burns
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and I
wish just to mention that we provided to
members of the house finance committee a
packet of information that we sent to
house Judiciary this packet of
information showed that our concern
about ballooning out of state requests
going to local governments are not
hypothetical they're not theoretical and
that is one of our major concerns with
the significant overhaul that house bill
66 does to current law so you do have
that information and we continue to
receive in examples of large outof state
right to know requests that
municipalities have received and we
wanted to make sure that we provide that
information to you I would also just
like to Echo um the comments made by the
officer earlier we agreed age with all
of the concerns raised and we have heard
similar concerns from police departments
around the state thank you thank you all
right so officer you wanted to come back
and have a second shot you thought of
something else
to but only last thing I wanted to touch
on here is in that paragraph where it
does state that a member of the media
regardless of where located May request
government records electronically one of
the things that we see is that media is
very Loosely defined at this point in
this day and age whether you have a
podcast a Blog uh and we see any
critical event that we have I will
receive tens of 20 requests from these
media Outlets or impromptu media Outlets
so the the problem is is say you are in
the state of Massachusetts and you want
to request something I can just become a
member of the media by creating a
podcast today and so that's something I
just wanted to raise a concern about
yeah it's it's hard to police if you
will okay thank you
all right so um I think we're going to
have to digest this all the all the what
we've heard I don't think we're quite
ready to act here so let's go on to
House Bill uh
111 um extending the position of the
right no no Ombudsman for two
years and recognize representative
Lynn so um I I guess what I would say on
that is um that
we the Judiciary Committee did what um
we did on that um and again from from a
policy perspective I think and and I I
want to say that I mean we had we had
significant debate on this bill because
there were different views um within the
Judiciary Committee I but I think
ultimately we concluded that the the
right to no EMB budsman is very new I
mean it's just got passed a couple of
years ago it in the context of the whole
fight over what costs should be able to
be imposed on somebody who makes a
request for
information um the the office of the
Ombudsman was part of that bill that was
passed last year it C it calls for you
know the uh the an appeal to be made to
the Ombudsman over the estimate for the
costs or or the costs that are actually
imposed when costs are allowed to be
imposed and so um we ended up concluding
that you know we should that maybe it
was too soon to do something about
changing the udman with it with all due
respect to the udman who I've met the
number of times he seems like a nice guy
I think he does a good he said he does a
good job um I again
this is you know the the money thing in
my view is is like the number one
consideration and so with you know I
you're going to do what you have to do
and I'm going to respect whatever you
decide to do because I think that the
that the budget is the number one
priority okay thank you
questions do we see any no no okay thank
you representative blind um so Mr udman
would you like to talk about this
bill okay
sure very basically for the part of the
bill that continues my agency please
turn on your microphone on I said that
I'll make it brief I basically I'm for
the part of the bill that will continue
my agency Beyond July 1st 2025 because
I'd like to know what to do because if I
know the agency is going to get
continued I got to go back and find out
whether I'm going to get recommissioned
so I would uh
it's been two years uh I've given you my
uh annual report the last time around
you've seen that obviously whether or
not you wish to continue it is up to the
legislature yeah thank you so and the
other portions of the bill I that's up
to you any questions let me let me just
tell you what I'm thinking about in
regards to this bill and sketch your
reaction and that is that um I think
that $170,000
a year when you're doing three cases a
month is not um is not reasonable so um
we have some other boards where they're
paid on a per case basis plus some
stipend for you know for the for the
answering the phone type of stuff and um
in particular one of our
boards um they're paid I think it's $200
every two weeks
plus $400 a case when they have a case
and so in in your case with with that
would end up being a much smaller amount
of money um and it would be a part-time
job not a full-time job no benefits all
the sort of thing so I don't know if if
we do that which is my my in inclination
you may or may not be appointed May or
not want such a job Etc but what's your
reaction to to doing that my reaction to
that is that those people have a support
I do not I am doing three or four
people's jobs to support me as the guy
that would get the pum if all I did was
hidle cases I'm not just deciding cases
and hearing cases and having my support
network reschedule a case uh do
expedited proceedings and Etc add your
own purchasing and moving and Etc the
things I mentioned in my report um
frankly I'm doing several people's jobs
and uh if you want to do it on a case-by
casee basis I think that you're going to
put a strain on anybody I'm
administratively attached to because
they would need to provide the support
that I'm currently providing myself and
I'm not sure that's going to be any
cheaper thank you okay all right other
any other questions no thank you very
much you're welcome so to me this one
feels like a retain because it's it's
spending money just like everything else
so do we that seem right to people yes
okay representative evil recommended I
make a motion to retain
hb11 okay we have a second second by
representative Sweeney all right any
discussion on that no okay uh all those
in favor please raise your hands all
right
unanimous assuming the clerk is for
[Laughter]
it okay good all right um very good
anything else we want talk about
today
we well what's your so I was thinking
that we got a lot of different input and
and maybe we ought to maybe maybe we
want to think about it maybe come up
with an amendment or something like that
we need to work on this I represent
Sweeny oh okay anybody else want to say
anything about I I agree I think we need
to work on let it stew over the weekend
or something okay good representative
Sweeny on uh House Bill 511 the federal
immigration authorities we do have the
drafted Amendment from the counties I
don't know if we're vot if we should
vote on it because we just got it so I
think if distribute it so people can
read it we can stew on that stew on that
too we could just work on it later but
it's okay what the County Association
sent over we had drafted up as an
amendment bill it is reading it it is
simple I just I don't want to jump the
gun on
it yeah do you want to talk about it
sure all right yeah come on
up all right so we're going to go back
to house bill 511 thank you and very
good see I can find there it
is great thank you representative
McGuire again Kate Horan New Hampshire
Association of counties so what this
amendment does is that if a county has a
contract for holds that covers all
expenses we will hold someone for 48
hours excluding Saturdays Sundays and
holidays to ensure that our costs are
covered and that agreement can be with
anyone the feds if the state wants to
contract with us so that we hold someone
great um if a county does not have a
contract because some counties are just
never going to get a contract Sullivan
County probably is never going to get a
contct
contract we will not hold them we don't
have to hold them because they don't
have space because they don't have space
they don't meet the requirements things
like that there's also
notwithstanding obligation language in
here to protect the anyone who does have
a contract so the contract that
Strafford County has with ice and the
rider on the Marat County contract and
if Rockingham Coos is in talks with
border control about a contract right
now those contracts would be protected
and we could hold them beyond the 48
hours so I think it's a fairly simple
Amendment it handles the money piece it
handles the litigation piece and if you
do this the counties will be very
appreciative and I'm happy to take any
questions okay um any questions
representa
M thank you and um just bear with me
here sure
um is there any reason that this has to
be specifically limited to Immigration
and Customs Enforcement I mean would it
be better to give you
have it be broader so um my
understanding is that detainers are only
an ice World thing they don't exist
anywhere else we're already covered
under warrants if you have state charges
pending um things like that so I think
we're covered on those other pieces
detainers are not criminal they're civil
and so I think that's the
difference yes go so that raises an
interesting question we're holding we're
going to hold people accused of a civil
crime in a criminal
jail 48
hours we we don't have we don't want to
debate the policy that is not our
intention Our intention is to just make
it legal so we don't get sued okay very
good other questions represent swing
thank you Mr chairman I not a question I
just to clarify on the policy side of it
not to get too weight into it the bill
as amended by criminal justice only
applies to inmates in New Hampshire so
it's only those inmates with ice
detainers that will then fall under this
provision so it's not nobody's going to
be going out and arresting people for
civil detainers it's only those inmates
in the system but the but go ahead but
theoretically if somebody is in for a
state charge and their state charge ends
then they and they are still
retained they're they're they're not a
criminal anymore or they're not an
inmate
anymore and I don't know I I will I will
say counties are pre-trial and 80 to 90%
of the people that counties are holding
are pre-trial they aren't
convicted okay
all right thank you so all right we will
keep this in mind all right thank you
all so we we have a house session
tomorrow uh caucus is at 9: I think is
it right we can leave all our stuff here
right yes sure that's good and then
we'll be back Friday at
10 Friday at oh Friday right right right
Friday at 1 or 1:15 whichever one it
is is it 115 I don't I think so 115
we're time again yes cuz we have to come
back from County yes thank
you okay well we got some work done
today a little
bit maybe not enough but
anyway e